Hello everybody!
Hey, that's me, yay!
I don't know how my mic is.
We did it!
I'm so tired.
Thank you everybody for the birthday wishes!
I'm so tired right now.
I'm so tired.
I'm sorry for making guys wait.
Post-concert I had to go get some tacos and it was...
And then my staff went the wrong way.
They took me to the wrong place.
They were like, why are we in a parking lot?
I was like, why are we in a parking lot right now?
I was so, I was so, it's two dokees.
Wait, maybe I'll just put myself here.
Now it's just one dokee.
They'll make it bigger and I'll cover her up.
This is my, it's a dokee show.
It's my birthday.
This is the post-concert.
I'm tired.
it was a very long day guys it was a very long day thank you
next seat for the aca-supa thank you thank you congrats on
the concert dokey we got many drunk to celebrate when is he
not drunk next you they go to aca-supa thank you thank you
no I have to stream maybe it was a little short stream but
also I felt bad because you guys all waited for me and i was
just like trying to trying to fix i i don't know i i thought
i had a plan but like it all fell apart everything fell
everything fell apart um not only i want to spend i want to
spend uh my birthday even if it's a little you guys are
gonna hear fireworks soon because they're celebrating my
birthday by the way that firework is for me but also we'll
have a real serious real like um actual professional
birthday we'll have birthday too birthday too when i get
back but today's still i got the birthday cake by the way um
i realize i don't have forks in my hotel room i realize i
don't have forks here i got and then i and then also i had
to eat it myself oh wait let me actually let me text someone
real quick let me uh let's see um
okay let me text i don't know i don't know i don't know i'm
just texting someone real well texting as i'm gonna message
uh message no the it guy had to go to the airport because
they're flying to some other convention and then he's coming
been he's flying back to la for some i don't fucking know
it's just like he's like i'm going to airport and i was like
wait i thought you're staying i thought you're gonna be here
for like a couple more and he's like uh yeah i'm flying back
and i was like what and and then my other staff was like
yeah he just yeah he just likes doing that like yeah IT guys
I have his router though I get to keep his router well I
don't get to keep it um my staff's gonna give it back to him
later after I'm done with it I knew I needed a portable
router they're like no it's okay the Marriott hotel is super
good for Wi-Fi stuff it's all right and I was just like are
you sure are you are you sure though and then they're like
no it's fine you have so how much high you have high-speed
internet and everything don't talk to yourself did you just
say you're well I'm leaving like I'm leaving wait what am I
leaving I'm leaving soon It's not like I'm gonna be here for
a while I was like I'm tired I'm so tired Don't talk
yourself Guys I don't know if you guys know this But I might
be in LA right now Don't say that Guys I don't know if you
guys know this But I may or may not be in LA right now guys
No way what whoa no way and my concert might have also been
in LA guys whoa there's like true well no way someone's
stopping and guys I Adam Expo my also be in LA right now too
and also the one-piece Dodgers I was not there at the
one-piece Dodgers event by the way I was oh oh by the way
the IT guy the IT guy was at the midnight Majan thing
apparently and he was telling us how he was a giant fight
that broke out after the cops left um but he was like i
couldn't sleep so i went to the midnight mahjong i was like
what yeah you know how um was that their convention with the
feet juice so instead of feet juice um uh at anime expo they
had midnight mahjong instead of feet juice
Thank you, the Akasupa, thank you, thank you.
As a foreigner, I was worried that I would miss the live.
Happy Dokey birthday, 20 or 60.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I'm doing this all on my laptop right now, by the way.
Oh, this is new, thank you, the Akasupa, thank you.
Congrats on the amazing concert and a happy birthday.
Despite your insistence that you are not a serializer, you
killed each and every song you brought to you.
There are so many beloved Oshis, never ever missed a bit.
How special experience you bring to us.
We love you.
Thank you, the Akasupa, thank you, thank you.
Do you guys like how I emoted on you?
You paid me to emote.
you guys you bought a ticket just so I can emote on you she
kept emoting you thought it was the end of the emote then I
started busting up the ghanem style yeah I started I started
flossing I started doing that the goth dance I started
ghanem styling I started and doing the chicken uh guys thank
you for the chance to super thank you thank you okay you
leaving canada for cost made your country lose okay guys we
were not winning against morocco guys guys it was a 20
chance that canada could win was it worth it um actually
it's happy 251st birthday to me i am older than america guys
thank you for the super chat thank you I hear, like, stray
fireworks right now.
Why did you do it to Canada?
Guys, guys, we always scored another goal when the concert
started.
That's crazy.
No, oh, wait.
Oh, I see the fireworks right now.
They're outside my door.
I see it.
Anyway, what do I want to say?
Thank you all for...
I'm sorry there were so many technical there were so many
technical difficulties and I was so stressed out and I'm
glad you guys still enjoy the concert I was like I was going
through a roller coaster of emotions I was okay wait I wrote
this down by the way um um I wasn't gonna say uh by the way
like I had my first meal of the day after the concert I
literally I felt like I was in switch up i was i wrote this
did i not write this down oh my god maybe oh i did not write
this down okay i wrote it in chat uh basic like i had my
first meal at around 6 p.m yeah 6 30 i had my first me
around 6 30 today on my birthday this is all my birthday i
wrote it in a chat while we were all waiting now i'm sorry
i'm so sorry that you guys all waited an hour and 10 was an
hour and 15 minutes because everything there was so many
things ago okay um i wrote it in the chat while we were all
waiting because i fucked up accidentally because uh there
even the tech guy was like are you sure we should be
starting at uh this time okay
after fireworks
all right uh what was i gonna say um okay so i woke up um i
stayed one day at the airport hotel before i had to go to
the actual hotel i am so Also, how's the mic, by the way?
I think the mic is, like, super sensitive right now because,
like I said, I'm using my...
I haven't used the streaming setup in so long.
Oh, wait, wait.
I have another phone I could use.
By the way, I accidentally brought one phone, too.
So I'm not moving because I accidentally brought one phone
because I fucked up.
I only brought one phone.
I didn't bring my other...
My actual streaming phone.
So...
so i'm using my the my phone that ashley used to uh call
people and stuff so let me where where is oh there it is um
guys okay i forgot a lot of stuff i forgot my charger too so
i was i forgot my headphones i forgot everything i forgot
everything i was so i was so no you guys don't understand i
was so stressed out i was like okay so this was uh no okay
i'm png because i was sending myself photos i had to send
photos to myself so i could um let's see all right let me
i'll choose a new background because other doki is
distracting me uh let's see there we go that's a photo there
you go uh
all right sorry uh someone messaged me i can't say who Yet,
yet, yet, anyway, uh, this is a post-concert photo, so
everybody's, oh, maybe I could get, I could send, use a
actual con, I should, I should just use a con, sorry, I'm
all over the place right now, I'm so, I'm so all over this
place, guys, it was like, oh, I could use an actual photo,
photo, give me a sec, guys, I'm sorry, guys, I'm sorry for
being all over the place, guys, uh, wait, My staff sent me a
cool photo of, oh, this is a good photo.
I'll use that photo.
Oh, my God, I'm trying to find, like, a good background to
use.
Because there's so many good photos, and I'm like, which
one?
Which one do I use?
There's so many good photos to use.
Okay, okay, I found it.
I found a good photo.
I found a good photo this time.
Okay, happy birthday to me.
I like my birthday.
It's my 251st birthday, guys.
Ah, hmm.
Okay.
Yeah!
Yeah, that's a good.
That's a good one.
Oh my god, thank you for that, like, Akasupa, everybody!
Thank you!
Well, I'm not fucked up with the fuck, but also, happy
birthday, don't keep it.
Kamiyoshi, Kamiyosomoshi, Papa's birthday.
I looked away for, like, one second, and then, oh, so many
super chats thank you everybody thank you many broken moms
powers super fucked up they drink too much that's some
fucking after party uh thank you much of the super thank you
thank you more balls thank you for super regina super thank
you thank you i'm proud of myself with his one can you read
my that you just don't worry i can't don't worry oh i know
which one i saw it don't worry i saw it you saw the jingle
you like my new outfit guys i told you it was worth it um
Even Akasufa, they could think.
Oh, my God.
It, like, unclicked itself.
I want you to jingle jangle through my two eyes.
I was fucking...
Yeah, that's right.
Sports bra.
Ah.
All right.
What...
Oh, I could show you...
Ah.
Let's see.
I'm trying to think, like...
Oh, okay.
So, wait.
All right, that's right, Matara.
I see you.
That's right.
Matara Khan didn't want to wish me a happy birthday in my
hotel room.
She's touching a grass right now.
Like a hag.
What did Matara do?
How dare she?
She's outside with her parents watching the fireworks
instead of wishing me a happy birthday in my hotel room.
I can't believe...
Am I not family enough to?
Is it your parents' birthday?
I don't think so it's a my birthday
She was like you're like girl, I'm gonna give some I've just
had a lot of pizza and my place is my my Airbnb is like two
minutes away.
I'm crashing out
I'm in the audacity
Anyway Um, what was I gonna say?
I'm already lost.
I'm, I'm, oh, okay.
I felt like a sweatshop worker at first because like, uh,
yesterday, for those who didn't know, I flew in to, um, LA,
literally yesterday.
Um, you know how I had a meet and greet panel?
Yeah, I had a meet and greet panel.
Um, um, but in between, I had to work on millionaire things
for this concert as well while, oh my gosh, I was like
fucking exploding at my manager about this because I was
just like, I'm black.
I had to record stuff and oh my god guys Guys, I'm gonna I'm
gonna break it to you about this I don't know why I was so
ambitious.
I don't I Don't know why I was so ambitious and felt I could
do it I was gonna shadow drop a new outfit like right now
like during this I was just like, BAM, new outfit.
And then I was going to release the birthday merch dedicated
to the new outfit.
And then I was just like, I can't.
You want to see the thumbnail, though?
We'll do it when I...
Special announcement.
New outfit.
What is wrong?
I was ready.
So yesterday, I was recording the voice back.
I was recording the voice back for it.
the birthday drop that was supposed to release today but i
was like i can't guys i'm so out i cannot do this anymore
this announcement surprise we're like we're gonna have a new
outfit like i think when i get back i'll do
you're so out of it i was gonna uh yeah i was gonna
is postponed whenever I'm back guys because the birthday
merch is related to the new outfit and I was gonna be like
BAM new outfit and then I'll be like here's the merch and
here's the birthday merch so birthday merch is postponed
until uh until I'm back home in Canada
but you guys wanna see the thumbnail though the thumbnail's
okay let me grab the thumbnail um uh oh yeah it's not here
you go guys guys it's actually pretty uh pretty on theme too
the thumbnail itself
i was gonna be like i was gonna change this thumbnail and be
like bam it's suddenly an outfit reveal just shadow drop and
then i just be like i just show up and be like happy
birthday and
happy birthday guys
but but uh it changed i can't i'm i'm i i'm too fucked up
right now i'm i i pre-gamed some
though I'm okay um what was it oh yeah back to being a
sweatshop worker um and then I basically I did a voice pack
recording yesterday for the birthday merch because I was so
and I had to record a uh do like another recording for
someone else um because it was like technically due when I'm
like in LA so I was like okay I gotta do all this because
I'm like you're like Doki why Every day was hell day.
Every day.
I could still shadow drop.
Don't test me.
I'll shadow drop.
I can just show.
I can still.
I can still shadow drop the outfit right now.
I can still do it guys.
I really.
I'll still drop.
I'll just I'll just like.
change clothes right now
oh yeah oh yeah that's why I was like I got yeah I pre-gamed
an empty stomach that is true yeah pre-gamed that's why I'm
so I need water oh yeah by the way I'm an entire okay I'll
show you guys the cake I took a picture of the cake I have
an entire cake and I have no fork and I was just eating it
with my finger like wow well IT, while the IT guy was trying
to fix the router issue, I was just like my finger because I
was like, I'm no, it doesn't fit the fridge.
It doesn't even fit the fridge.
And so I was just like, what do I do?
Women, please.
I'm sorry.
It's, I've been going through a lot, guys.
my birthday for another three hours it's all i had was tacos
and cake guys that's all i ate today i'm so tired on my
birthday that was a switch okay okay so um and then right
after the meeting greet i had no time i had to prep our
panel for us because i everybody was going to be streamed
Everybody was going to be on my stream for the panel, so I
had to prep everybody, like, right after me didn't greet, so
I had, like, less than, um, like, I had, like, 30 minutes to
set everything up for us, and then, um, and then right at
the panel, um, what did I do?
I was, like, freaking out to my manager, oh, yeah, um, I
still haven't packed yet.
I still haven't packed yet.
So I was finishing up.
Wait, I was finishing.
Oh, yeah, I had to send, like, streaming tickets to
everybody.
That was part of the concert, too.
And then, like, oh my god, I had, like, chat logs of
everything.
Let me check.
What was I talking about to people?
I was sending people, yeah, I was sending people stuff.
Oh, and I got the art.
I feel so bad.
I got the artwork, like, yesterday for the merch stuff, too.
Um, oh my, and anyway, so I had, like, I didn't pack yet, so
right after panel, I had to finish up the recording, the
other recording, and I went straight, I had 30 minutes to
pack, and then, what's the 30, I don't even remember, guys,
and after I finished all the work stuff, I had only 30
minutes to pack, so I packed everything, and I realized I
didn't pack everything, because I forgot to bring my
streaming phone, and also, my headphone, and also, um, I
think that's it, that's all.
that's and also my charger for my phone so i had to buy a
new charger i had to buy a new head like a like a i bought a
cheap headphone thing for myself just because i was just
like i would i knew i was going to be at anime expo so i
just wanted to listen to music while i walk around and then
also i had to buy i didn't buy a new phone though i'm just
using my my actual like personal phone and oh my gosh wait
what am i doing i should be chilling right now i'm oh my god
happy birthday to me why this has to be the most messy
birthday stream ever like the concert today and this is
actually my most messy i'm sorry i just was i just want to
spend time with you guys i'm sorry if it's so messy i just
want to spend time with my dragons the concert because i
won't talk about the concert even i'm like i was a sweatshop
worker but like i still had fun but like not the part where
i was a sweatshop worker though that that part wasn't fun
that part was not fun um in truth i'm not drunk i'm actually
very sober right now because i had a lot of tacos I had a
lot a lot of tacos alright here you go I feel bad because my
staff worked really hard trying to get everything in time
and then I was like guys I know we all worked super hard
trying to get the merch drop done on July 4th but we might
not be dropping it anymore on July 4th I'm sorry
I'm so sorry We all worked so hard trying to get it ready Um
Get it ready by today And they're like Do you know how to
open the show?
I was like I know how to open the shop And they're like
teaching me how to open this Because I have to open the
online shop myself Because my staff are Because it's July My
staff is busy Because they're also working at the The um
nom's cafe booth that are selling my stuff and then so they
were like okay you're gonna be able to do it i was like yeah
and then they're like okay we set everything up we have the
pushbacks done we have it all set up we added the extra
stuff and then and i was just like yeah i got this and then
i went to prep stream and then i had the router issue and i
was like gosh i don't really i'm I'm tired.
I think it would be better if I just be like the special
announce, special, sorry, it feels very anti-climatic.
This is post-concert, not concert, so cute.
I'm sorry, it's so anti-climatic.
New outfit revealed.
That's the announcement.
Just get very...
Very...
It's like...
Okay, anyway.
Um...
Bro.
Okay.
Special announcement!
Anyway.
Um...
You still...
I could still do it, guys.
Technically, I could still do the shadow.
That's gonna be like...
That's actually gonna be the craziest shadow drop.
Be like, bam, I show up.
Here you go.
I mean, technically, it's how I feel right now.
There's still time.
There's, don't, don't keep doing.
All right, anyway.
And then, like, what was it?
Okay, so, and then I did do all those tweets in.
everything and please ask the hotel staff for it for next
time um what was i gonna say okay so then i packed
everything obviously i forgot a lot of stuff while packing
and then i i need water
this is a big ass hotel room by the way just for me
okay anyway um i got on the plane um but i was tempted to
just hop on a hop on discord on my phone and then just just
tick tock you guys on the bed i almost did it i i wasn't
able to get pen light while the concert because he was busy
picking up is there anything you can do well think of the
super chat thank you thank you no i'm sorry i'm sorry it's
actually way out of my own hands guys it's it's it's it i
can't i'm sorry the pen lights was was a venue exclusive and
it was a venue exclusive unfortunately and they it was very
limited quantity I was so stressed out about that I I was
okay sorry let me go back from the beginning I keep like
bouncing in between how all right um basically I arrived in
um LA but I had to stay at a hotel um at the airport because
they didn't have I don't know maybe I'll talk to them about
it i don't know but basically i didn't have uh um yes the
vet goon juice was also a venue exclusive goon juice sloppy
sisters i didn't even get to see what honorary mexican and
sloppy sister drink looked like i don't because someone did
anyone take pictures of the drinks i only got the goon juice
because i was like i didn't even realize i was drinking on
an empty stomach no wonder it hit me hard.
I could only get the goon juice.
Um, anyway, fuck, I keep, okay, so I had to stay at the
hotel, um, at, because, like, my hotel wasn't ready yet
until, uh, my hotel that was, uh, closer to the concert
wasn't ready yet, because, like, they, everything was booked
up, There was another concert going on, like, you know,
maybe going on right still going on right now.
I don't know.
The one that's evening.
There was my concert.
There was World Cup.
There was the Dodgers game.
There was, there was Anime Expo.
So a lot of stuff was happening.
So I couldn't.
So I was just, I had to stay at that hotel.
And then I was so stressed out and tired because I had a
million.
out that uh they uh first off the merch website wasn't
working because you guys remember the cart disappeared so i
thought so like i thought for the longest time that it was
because technically the website wasn't live but the website
was live and they were like no the website's up now it's
ready to go and i was like oh okay where's the cart
where's the cart they're like what you mean i was just like
how am i supposed to check out like so so they didn't notice
the cart was missing on the website like we we i was like
guys how did you not see the car like how did you not i mean
technically didn't see the body i noticed the cart was
missing and then so so they're like oh we gotta fix it and
then when they fixed it when they fixed it um um uh they
were like oh okay it's live now and then also margaret they
was super chat thank you they have her thank you and then it
was live but then they're then everything sold out in 20
minutes and i was so confused i was just like i was like
guys what there's no what I thought this was a unlimited
order a unlimited order means it's unlimited how does it
sell out like I'm so stressed out about it so somehow there
was a miscommunication where the distributor when we said
unlimited pre-order they're like a hundred
Thank you guys.
Thank you guys so much.
I did not expect to sell a hundred of each item within like
less like within like 30 minutes.
So each item had only a hundred items.
So so that's why it's so yeah.
100 equals unlimited.
And I was like, so I was so stressed out because I was just
like, guys, I, you know, stressed out for you guys, because
you guys were like, why did you just shadow drop?
Like, that's why I wanted to shadow drop the new outfit.
Like, why did you shadow drop why did you shadow drop uh
this the merch store out of nowhere if it was very limited
yeah yeah so so i was so confused because i wouldn't have
warned you guys to be like guys there's a very limited
quantity but it was like there was it was supposed to be
unlimited priorities because it's like online um yeah So,
but the thing is, it was already late at night, too, when I,
we've, like, it was already, like, 8 p.m.
or some shit, like, yesterday, so 8 or 9 p.m.
So, people who were working on the website already clocked
out.
They were not, like, they're not work hours anymore.
So, they had to fix it tomorrow, like today.
They had to fix it on July 4th.
But even then, they were like, we don't know if we can fix
it on July 4th, because for some reason, there's a fucking
national holiday on July 4th.
I don't fucking know why they're not celebrating my birthday
instead.
than the fucking 250th anniversary of america i mean this is
my 251st anniversary of my birthday like no way real that's
crazy so um she's right you know so yeah so so i was just
like what the fuck is going on like like are we gonna have
the merch fixed and And so, um, so, so I was really worried
because I was so scared it was not going to be fixed by the
4th because they were like, it's July 4th, so why would they
be working on July 4th?
So I was like, how did no one got this?
Like, I was so stressed out because I was like, no one got
this.
How was I the one that saw there was no card?
There's...
yeah and i was like why was the why is it we saw it we were
like where's the card like so i was super stressed out about
that and then we were told that they bring very limited i'm
so sorry about the limited quantity um merch for people at
the venue i'm so sorry if you guys didn't get the merch i'm
really really sorry that one was also pretty limited as well
um i think I'm really sorry but I still hope you guys were
us were able to you know okay it was really funny because um
when we found out how much merch um was for me at the venue
um because it's definitely because we sold out the venue but
we didn't bring enough merch that would appease the entire
venue and I was just like and I was I felt so stressed out
about it because there was nothing we could do because the
the merch was already that was like the merch that was made
like it was like they were like underestimating how much
they were going to be selling but we sold out everything and
um and so the thing was uh when uh so i was stressed out
about that because i felt so bad i was like they have to fix
it they have to fix the merch store but by before the
concert because when the merch just sold out at the concert,
they can't order it anymore.
Like we don't even have an online store to order it.
So I was like, you guys gotta, you guys gotta fix it by
tomorrow.
Because like, when you sell out the physical merch, what the
fuck are they gonna do?
Like, yeah.
I was just like, what do we, because they're like, we're
gonna have a QR code, we're gonna scan it.
And then it's gonna lead you to the online store.
And I was like, what's the point of having a QR code to scan
it and everything sold out?
yeah yeah so um yeah so i was just like what are you gonna
do like cry everyone will cry i didn't want you guys to cry
so i still want to have a chance for you guys to still order
it even if it's sold out on venue so luckily it got fixed
like in the afternoon while i was like at adamant
I got like but I was so stressed out last night about it and
um and then okay by the way the dog shirt was my idea
because I was like we're gonna sell out anyway fucking bring
the dog shirts at least we can at least we can sell the dog
shirts I didn't even we didn't suggest atheists we were just
like we're like I was like to the venue people I was like I
told my staff I was like tell them that we're selling our
dog shirts because it's everything's gonna sell out anyway
at least we can move the dog shirt sock out of the way yeah
and then so and then they were like okay but like we the
venue people were like we have to take a cut because it's
like part of like like the deal like if we're selling
anything at the venue they have to take a percentage off and
they're like my staff was like are you sure and then i
looked and i was in the room with our um distributor like
like with nom's cafe and they're like but like what
percentage are you gonna take blah blah blah and then it was
like a big meeting between me nom's cafe who's our
distributor um my event staff and my manager and then we
were like having this debate on whether or not we um sell
our dog shirts at we were having this debate and then and
then my manager we were like if they're gonna take a
percentage of we should like it's our merch like and then
but we were like But then, and then, and then my manager was
like, Doki, like, we have so many dog shirts.
And then I was like, that can't be, I thought we've been
moved.
And then I looked at the nonce cafe people.
I was like, if we sell out on our dog shirts, do we still
have dog shirts left?
And they were like, we have so many.
they're like no we are no we are not sold out dokey there's
still so many and i was like bring it to the venue bring the
dog shirt
so so weird i was like oh fucking bring the dog shirt to the
venue just bring just get that shit out of it just try and
sell that too many dog shirts I will never tell you guys how
many we ordered I thought it would be the next big thing I
thought it would be my next adventure capital dog shirts I
was just like I was like bring the dog shirts I don't care I
don't care anymore just get the rid of the stock.
And not, I was not enough.
And so my brilliant idea of putting the dog shirts, they're
going to bury you in the desert outside Doki Lawn with the
unsold dog shirts, cursed cowboy treasure.
Petra, I said, thank you, thank you, thank you, and then we
sold out at the concert, I was like, how many did we bring,
and they were like, we brought 150 to Adam at Expo, and we
sold out a hundred, we sold out, we, they brought half of
that to, to the concert venue, because they were, they
basically sold a lot during Adam Expo, so they had like half
of 150 left, and then you still we sold out of the concert
we're 150 less dog shirts guys we're 150 less dog shirts
we're slowly chipping away the dog shirt mountain uh nice
it's so we're chipping away the dog shirt mountain guys you
how many years live Like, okay, anyway, so I'm glad we
brought the dog shirt to the venue, because people were,
because apparently you guys were like, I don't even have a
dog, but at this point, fuck it, she keeps telling me to buy
a dog shirt, I might as well since I'm here, and I was like,
yes, I did it, there's nothing else to buy, so you're gonna
buy the dog shirt, I fucking did it.
I knew it.
You're just as desperate as me.
The plan is working.
At this point, we feel bad.
Yeah.
The business strategy.
The not very subliminal messages are working.
You're buying the dog shit.
You're not.
Next, see, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
That's where you're actually.
talking about that too we were trying to figure out ideas on
how to get rid of the dog shoots and we're planning that's
one of our ideas that we want to do in the future when we
make a dad plush like a build-up bear we make a build-up
bear either dragon or a dragon we're planning like planning
on maybe a dragon or a long gun and it will fit we'll fit
the dog shirt and we think the long gun works the best
because it's like the body works it just build a goon with
only one outfit and it's only the dog shirt oh thank you the
magenta soup but thank you thank you when we tell us how
many dog shirts you made if you i will tell you how many dog
shirts we made when we sell out when we finally sell the
last dog shirt thank you for the magenta soup but thank you
thank you um build a goon workshop exactly uh this is this
is the one Ongoon gets something.
But yeah, anyway, so that was like one of our ideas.
So anyway, so that was one of the things I was super
stressed out about, which was the merch.
And so I was glad we were able to fix it.
Like that's something I was stressed out about last night
because we're, you know, we were able to fix it.
So thank God.
And so you guys could still order the merch even if it's
sold out.
I don't even know who won the skateboard, by the way.
I realized it was a silent auction.
So it didn't matter if I bid on it because you guys wouldn't
even know it was me.
Or maybe it was me.
Who knows?
Maybe I might have bid one time.
Well, I think I might have bid one time just because I
realized it was silent auction.
So I'm like, well, it's a silent auction.
So you'll think all of them is me, technically.
It could be me, you know?
It could have been me.
skateboards now um um what else oh yeah so that was what was
stressing me out last night and also i didn't get the
postcards last night i was supposed to get the postcard last
night so i wouldn't feel stressed out about signing the
postcard today because last like at last minute um so so i
was stressed out about that because I was like, where's the
boob scourgeys?
I thought I was going to get the boob scourgeys to sign.
So this is where the sweatshop thing came to play.
Next, I didn't even know there was no standee.
I was so confused because I thought it was going to be... I
think the standee never came in in time or they weren't able
to get it done in time, but they didn't tell me.
Next, see, I'm so sorry.
We got baited.
Next, we got I didn't know.
I was like, where's the standee?
Am I supposed to sign?
Is that what they do?
Oh, there was no, everybody was just so busy.
There was no standing, no standing.
I got baited.
We got baited together.
The Knoxle, Knoxle, they use a magenta suit, but they, thank
you.
I've seen a dragon think about making a three-piece suit out
of a dog shirt.
He said he was on the large side, so I thought I could use
up quite a few.
They use a magenta suit, but thank you.
you thank you so that's it next thing thank you with the
super chat thank you thank you i didn't even know i was also
wondering where the stand he was too um what was i gonna say
okay yeah um uh i was wanting to go into abandon wait who
won the skateboard did you guys not fit on the skateboard
because you thought there was a stand he or like were you
guys like thank you oh the sanny's at the end so i'm saving
my money at the end and some think of a super chat the thing
of a five gifted ships they could thank you um what was i
gonna say uh oh my gosh i'm sorry i'm like i'm going all
over the place in my tangents so like i've already lost my
train of thought um did you double my skateboard bid why
does my oh she hate me papa smirk thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you i am dokey bird's number one fan
I am, dude, I will have the best Doki Shrine.
Um, what was I saying before I got distracted, guys?
I forgot already.
I still realized there was no music, but, like, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
My commentary is the music at this point.
okay postcard okay so um so this is foreshadowing as to what
happened so we got the postcards I think like um we got the
postcards around 12 ish and the concert starts at 2 so I was
locked in a room and I started signing I was just like I
started signing I'm just like and it was like post oh yeah
okay here's the here's the tldr i'll do a little spark notes
real quick getting there so i woke up early i had to wake up
super early i had to wake up at 7 30 a.m so i can go to the
go to my new hotel i got to the new hotel and then my room
wasn't ready and so they're like we will we don't we'll call
you when your room's ready by the way you want to know what
time p.m.
they call this they call this at like 4 p.m.
so from I tried to check in at eight and my room wasn't
ready until 4 p.m.
so anyway I had no hotel room so I had to leave my luggage
at the concierge and then I left and then I met up with my
uh one of my one of my staff members who got me and uh an
anime expo uh anime expo ticket so she took me to anime expo
and then we split up because like it was safer for me to
walk by myself so uh i was just like walking around like we
she just gave me she's like this is where anime expo is i
was like all right and i split up with her and then i went
to the artist alley slash exhibit hall and then I spent $700
on one in one booth exhibitor booth because the oh my gosh
wait I need to show you guys the clothes I got wait let me
grab it I have so many two clothes oh my god I spent a
thousand dollars on clothes guys I'm gonna spend my card got
locked I spent around more than a thousand dollars I have
like new jackets and hoodies and wait I'll just show you
guys like our artist catalog actually uh let me show you
guys the artist catalog that I got it from um I think that's
I know I sent it to one of my friends because they're like
what are you gonna do at anime expo I'm gonna buy clothes
I'm gonna buy so many clothes that's like and I sent them
the catalog that I bought it I was gonna like I was like
that this is number one destination that I had to go to
there I went to this is where this is the place where I
spent $700 by the way this is American it was $700 American
it was like oh my gosh okay I bought the I bought big bad I
bought big bad I bought the crock hoodie I bought the oh
wait I show you it was so I really like the style they have
more than this too by the way this is just like a miniature
catalog of their stuff but um here I'll show you guys this
one was where I spent $700 and so um I bought I bought the
big bad jacket I bought the croc hoodie I it and then I
bought the uh what's I bought I bought the uh what else I
bought the logo a logo sling a green one and I bought beware
and I bought napclub too and then I bought uh I think that's
it I think there was more they had more than this they had
more than this it's I yeah they were also oh my god that I
know it's real drip it's real drip it was so cool i love all
the clothes that they had there and all oh no that's what
i'm seeing anyway so i was there for 40 minutes uh i forgot
to buy a hat i was gonna buy a hat but i don't wear hats a
lot too that's the thing i didn't buy a lot i didn't buy
hats because i also don't wear hats a lot so um um so i i
but they had really cool hats um Anyway, so I I'm gonna have
to buy another suitcase apparently apparently.
That's what my staff told me I was gonna say anyway, I got
like I got oh I bought like a really which where is it?
Let me show you guys other stuff.
I bought I bought from this store, too I love her stuff too.
I bought a really cute jacket from her
i'll save it but i also spent money in this booth too
this one i bought the i love to yapshire i bought the the
yellow jacket there i bought the green sweater and yeah and
i bought the happy lucky tiger i bought those three as well
um what else oh i i have a oh my gosh i don't let me see who
what's who's the artist
who's this artist
is that the artist okay all right let me grab the art grab
their catalog
bella plus canvas is that the artist no that's where they
got the shirt printed
they got this shirt printed at Bella Plus Campus so I don't
even know who the artist is they don't have like any logo or
anything oh I should have got your card
I don't oh wait is this there okay this looks like just a
fucking clothing brand okay this okay uh wait i have toll
text is that their name toll text no it's like what's your
fucking who are you okay maybe i know what to do who are you
okay that's a shirt
guys i'm trying to find the artist right now i have to move
my i'm trying to find the artist real quick who are you
who's the artist for this shirt it's a cute shirt too
okay wait the thing is i don't want to look through artist
cat i don't want to look the catalogs of everybody I really
want to show you guys this shirt I this artist shirt I
bought because it's really fun it's really really really
funny it's it's really really really funny okay is this
please where is your cat I should I'm trying to find it guys
it's very important I swear to God it is so important okay
wait wait let me see I'm looking through the shirts why
don't you put your logo on here I don't understand where's
your logo
I don't want to take a picture of it because I can't be
bothered because I only have one phone.
I only...
Okay.
Let me see, I can find it.
This is very important.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday, Doki.
I had a great time at the concert and met some pretty cool
dragons.
I gotta say the Goonju's got to me I was feeling it on my
flight back home, but we're thinking of the Akasufa.
Thank you.
Thank you Okay, wait, wait, wait.
I can find it.
I can find this guys.
Give me a sec.
I will find this.
It's the one thing I want to find right now.
Let's see.
AX 2026 guys give me the website guys maybe i'll find an
okay wait wait i know it was an exhibitor okay wait anime
expo map there you go i'm gonna look at the map guys it was
an exhibitor okay what it's just all numbers how am i
supposed to know who's in that how am i supposed to know
where is the Where's the list?
It's just not...
Okay, exhibit.
Where's the list?
Where's the list that tells me who's in the exhibitor?
Oh, there it is.
Where's the list?
Where is the list?
Where's the fucking list?
Where are the numbers?
What do they mean?
What the fuck do these numbers mean?
How am I supposed to know?
Guys, no.
I will not stop until I find it.
I really need to find this, guys.
You guys don't understand.
I'm desperate right now.
okay wait wait wait exhibitor hall anime expo usually they
tell you the names oh exhibitor list there you go i found it
i'm i'm combing through this i need you guys to know what
shirt i got this is very important this is actually so
important right now okay i remember the numbers i think it
was this number uh it was not this number i think it was
this number oh
my god it was this one i found it i found the shop i found
it guys okay i need you guys to the reason why i need you
guys to i really the only reason why i need you guys to know
exactly what shop i was
this was this was their shop and guess what shirt i bought
if you had to guess if you had to guess which shirt do you
think i buy from the store and they have only one shirt up
on there's only one shirt but it's only one shirt right now
I bought a lot of shirts from the this is not the only shirt
I bought I swear to God but this might be one of the shirts
I bought so this is there's a reason why I was so desperate
in making sure I find this a particular store because I
bought this shirt.
Peep, peep, boop, boop.
My good shoes.
Anyway, anyway.
I mean, they had other good, they have, guys, they had other
good shirts, okay?
It just so happened that I also bought this one as well.
Okay, they had a lot of really good, I also bought this one
too.
I thought like, I thought this one was also good.
Let me show you guys real quick.
To the surprise of no one, I also bought this shirt.
I also bought this shirt and then they have a lot they have
a lot that's not like on the shop right now um yeah there's
like some that's not even on the shop let me see if I could
find your other shirts that they have that's not on the shop
right now Oh, this one, too.
I have this one.
I bought this one, too.
This one's a good shirt.
I also bought this.
So that's how I feel every day right now.
I ask, but it never, I ask, but I'm, it never comes true.
Every day.
I hope that one day I won't be stressed out.
But today's not that day, unfortunately.
leave but the very that i also have this shirt too and don't
yeah one day maybe if i start wearing the shirt it'll happen
guys maybe maybe maybe when i start wearing it it'll come
true um anyway so i visited like four different I visited
four different booths for the sorry I lost my train oh sorry
I'm just like thinking about something right now oh yeah for
for for anime expo and then on the fifth booth I was gonna
buy a really okay this was gonna buy it let me it was a
hoodie i remember exactly what hoodie it was too i was so
sad i was so sad that wait oh i can't find it wait let me
find it on twitter i need to show you guys this was the
exact hoodie i was about to buy i was i swear to god if it's
sold out i i i would be so sad if it's sold out tomorrow
because i really really wanted this hoodie i i really need
to understand okay um try and find it right now where is it
where it was in artist alley i know it was in i know you're
in artist alley i know you i see you i saw you in artist
alley this this is sleep deprived sleep deprived is still
don't know why i'm still stressed out it's over okay i'll
describe it it was it was really cute it was a it was called
a weenor dog diner and it was a it was like it was so cute
it was a hoodie and it was called weenor dog diner and i was
about to buy it and then and like my car stopped working i I
need my card stopped working.
I was like, why is that card not working?
I'm good.
I need a tissue.
I need a blow by this.
I think it's like post-stress disorder.
I think it's like post-dress.
I think, yeah, I need the thinking.
Oh, my God.
Like, I think it's just, it's just, what is it called it's
like leftover stress that's still in my body but i'm like
what are you stressed out about anymore like it's over but
it's still like in my body because of everything building up
and like it's still there it's yeah and i was using my card
and they're like oh it's it got declined it was like what
and i was like it had no more cash on me because you want to
know why had no more cash on me when i was spending seven
hundred dollars on on that one booth i had to use i i only
currency exchange a thousand dollars so i spent i used up
all my cash because it was they could only do tap and my
card has a limit on tap so i was just like i guess i'll
spend my cash so so that card has a forced limit on it and
it doesn't go beyond and if i could do it's okay if it's
chip but it has a force limit when it's tap so i was like i
guess i'll use up my cash here and then so i bought like i
was gonna buy a hoodie and um so i was just using cash on
and up because i was just like oh if it's tab i might as
well just um well if it's like yeah so so i was just like oh
okay so then i i only had all the cash I had left, I had
like less than a hundred dollars.
Like I had like a hundred, like less than a hundred, less
than a hundred dollars left.
And I wanted to buy a hoodie and a t-shirt, but it was like,
and like, I think it was like a hoodie, t-shirt and
something else.
It was more than a hundred dollars.
And I was like, I was like, I'll use my card, but they had
chip.
So then I put it in and it was declined.
I was like, oh, I have this other card, but I forgot that
other card was locked too.
I forgot about the other card was locked.
so like because i've i never unlocked it because i because i
hate it because i was like well this other card the other
card limit is like really low so now i was like i'm never
gonna use that card because the limit is like around like uh
it's like around two thousand dollars so i was just like
well i'm not gonna use it because like uh because like i i
don't want to like hit the limit too soon so i was just like
i'm gonna use this other card because it has a high limit
and then but they locked my high limit card and i forgot i
never unlocked the other card too and the consequences of
well if I'm like on a business trip 2k like if not business
if I'm on like anime expo anime expo gone I spent a thousand
dollars in 40 minutes like it's 2k by the way it's 2k
Canadian it's 2k Canadian it's it's a it's yeah so yeah it's
not like 2k it's 2k like a thousand something american so um
yeah and then uh and like i i keep asking them to raise the
limit but they're like you have to reapply again and i was
like i hate my bank i hate my bank i hate my bank so much
and then and um i didn't and then so uh so i was like oh
it's locked and i tried three card like two cards i only
have two cards i only brought two cards with me and they
were all locked and I was just like I'm sorry I'm I'm from
Canada I'm sorry I'm from Canada they locked my code I'll
come back later
I'm sorry I'm Canadian
to god i swear to god if i come back tomorrow and it's the
wiener dog daughter hoodie is gone i swear to god please we
launched a morocco visa versey come is gone all we have is
home and then during all that my staff member before she
left uh um by the oh yeah before all of that um it was
everything was too heavy so then i got picked up by my staff
member and then she took all my bags so i was like shopping
time again and then before i went shopping she was like here
have a bottle of water uh because you don't have water on
you i was like thank you staff and then i put the well i
took a sip and i put the water in my bag and then little did
i know it was a cheap ass fucking water and the cheap ass
fucking water bottle cap slightly loose.
So my entire bag, I was like, when I was like walking around
Odyssey Alley hoping to buy my Weiner Dog Donner hoodie, I
felt my bag being wet.
And I was like, that's weird.
Why is it wet?
That's weird.
And then I opened my bag, I touched the bottom, and I felt
water yeah so my bag had a little accident at least it
didn't it's not the full water bottle the it wasn't the full
water bottle that got drained but it was like maybe it was
just like like one-third a cup I guess so everything got wet
in my bag and so like everything so at the so I was so sad
and I couldn't and then also during that I got a I got a
message from my staff and she was like you gotta go back to
the hotel room meet the postcards are here and I was just
like and I messaged back I was like wait let me let me last
booth and i'm gonna come back it was for the weiner dog
diner hoodie always remember you weiner dog diner hoodie i
and then my cards got declined and i that i didn't have
enough cash on me
new lady so and then and then they're like they're like all
right all right they're like there's the post and then they
locked me in one of the their hotel rooms and they're like
it's signing time get ready to sign get ready okay i'm gonna
say it was 200 vip tickets so they're like get ready to sign
200 postcards in two hours it's just like and i started
signing by the way my passport got wet too my my passport
got wet during the incident as well by the way so there was
that as well during it anyway because my passport was in my
bag um forgot to mention that too and then and then they're
like all right and i was like guys are you sure it was 200 i
thought it was 250 and they're like okay well we're gonna
check with we're gonna check with um the other the
organizers um the the other the concert producers and double
check with you and i was because i was like are you guys
sure it's 200 this is foreshadowing by the way are you guys
sure it's 200 i remember i it was 50 VIP tickets that we
sold and so they're like no it they just oh they just
confirmed it's 200 and I was like all right and start
signing oh by the way um some lucky dragons I did like a
little gotcha in there so because I also messed okay so
there were some that I sort of messed up but then like I was
just like I was like if you got something where it was like
example if your number has an a or a b it's because i
accidentally wrote the same number twice and i just wrote a
and b and i was like find your twin
because i was like they're like you act everybody's done and
i i may or may not have done that more than one it's like
number 155 a number 155 B I'm trying to match make yeah and
I wrote on it I'm giving you guys side quests right there
and also wrote on the postcard find your twin
so if you have a card that says a or b i guess i was i was
really worried that i i was just really worried um that i
couldn't get it done in time so i was just like yolo and
like well thank you a super chat thank you thank you i don't
know if i want to do an 800 b8 beam head up um it's a dope
yeah it's a i actually created a speed dating side quest uh
jacotta thank you super chat thank you thank you other
gotchas is i heard i already saw it but someone got 67 and
69 and they both met up with each other um and also um and
also i had um um all 200 cards plus okay guys fight side
thank you the akasupa thing thank you happy birthday ducky
sorry i'm late i was in charge of my family's firework oh we
had a good firework show and we just finished the concert
was amazing thank you the akasupa thing thank you guys enjoy
the concert anyway so um um there is uh four dragoons um all
of you some There are four to, I'm sorry, six lucky dragoons
that got a lucky dookie doodle on their postcards.
Each one, there's like regular goon, there's regular goon,
chonky goon, long goon, dad, and a goon.
Where's the six?
I don't remember what was the six one.
I think the six one was another regular goon.
So there's six...
doodles uh for the postcards and um and yeah that's really
it that's all i was gonna say so there's like some i don't
remember what numbers i put i just can't i just drew one
every couple of i was like okay i'm gonna doodle one for x
amount anyway remember i said they confirmed it was 200 um
so basically uh i was at the the venue you know getting
ready for the concert and then I think it was like 10 like
was it was like 20 minutes before the oh no it was 15
minutes before the pre-show was about to start and then like
15 or 20 minutes and they're like Doki will you need you to
sign 40 luckily I had 158 a and 158 B so like I did
apparently I did 10 mispron- 10 mispronors I got, I got,
there were 10 dragoons that got matched up together, so
thank God for that, like because it was 250 like
so anyway anyway, um they were like, at least it's not 50 I
had to, it's so So they were like, Doki, we need you to 20
minutes before the pre-show.
Doki, we need you.
And we need you to sign work cards.
And then they locked me in the bathroom.
Because I had decided.
I had decided discreetly.
And then they locked me in the bathroom to sign.
Five more cards.
That's why I was like, I'm in the sweatshirt right now.
I was just like, I'm gonna keep signing.
I'm gonna keep signing.
Yeah.
That's why I'm so delusional right now.
I'm so living in that.
I'm sitting in the cards.
I'm just like, I knew it was 250.
I can do it.
I was like, I'm pretty sure it was 250, guys.
I'm like, no, it's 200.
And I'm like, all right.
I'm saying 210.
Yeah.
yeah um it's because the backstage was located uh it was
like not easy to get to it was easier it was close not not
not not easy it was i was closer to the bathroom than i was
to the backstage
i just happened to be closer to the bathroom when they told
me so they needed me to sign it now so they're like bathroom
time so some of your postcard you know which postcard i know
for sure was signed in the bathroom if you have a lucky 250
you by the way if you if you are 250 i know for sure that
one was signed
yeah yeah yeah and then and you know so yeah so anyway um uh
oh my gosh it was something else i wanted oh yeah anyway i
thought it was over because i signed extra two this time But
apparently, I, okay, I signed one extra postcard.
But apparently, I went to go back to prep for the concert.
And then a staff member came up to me and was like, you need
to sign one last card.
And I was just like, what happened?
I thought, and they're like, one of them had soap on.
so it's just like I have one card it was just full it was on
it was stacks I put yeah one of the cards had soap all over
it so I decided one more card they had no way so yeah lots
of gotcha and that one's so I decided a lot and then I was
done and I was done and I was allowed to I was freed from
the sweatshop I did the one out of one card special with
soap so so I was freed from the sweatshop but yes I was also
um super stressed out um because like I said it was very
scuffed in the beginning and I'm so sorry like obviously I
didn't know what was going on obviously I was just like what
the fuck is the guy you know I want this concert to I'm a
perfectionist so I want his concert to be smooth selling to
be perfect and everything obviously it was not perfect
because um in the beginning there was like you know a lot of
technical difficulties coming in the beginning and then the
live stream itself was not supposed to go offline by the way
for those who are wondering wondering why it's a live stream
it was not supposed to go offline because there was supposed
to be another router that the other router was linked to the
YouTube stream and it went down for some reason it never
came back up it never came back up that's why the live
stream went down because it was supposed to be on the entire
time it wasn't supposed to be an offline chat because I
wanted to keep the chat archive so I could I don't know why
they just couldn't because my manager was the one i was
communicating to the technicians behind the not the spawn
stream it was the one on youtube so um so it was supposed to
be the one on youtube and that's why the stream went offline
and i wanted to keep the chat log so luckily some a dragon
saved the entire chat log of the event so i'm really
thankful for that because i wanted to like re-watch the chat
log to see how your reactions were for each song um really
happy that someone actually um kept the logs because like i
said i really wanted to i really wanted to see what your
reaction were when you were watching it watching the
streaming tickets and everything so that stressed me out a
lot too when i found out my manager was was not happy about
it he was he was not happy about it he actually stayed up um
he stayed up the whole night because my manager's european
and it was obviously super late at night for him so he up
the whole night just to like make sure everything goes
smoothly and like um you know things were not going smoothly
so we were all super stressed out about it and everything
and then uh what else stressed me out there there was like
multiple things that was like stressing me out oh yeah
accidentally making a waiting room an hour early because i
thought i i forgot the pre-show it I I knew the pre for
those who didn't know I fucking played apex legends for the
pre-show so for those who were confused I played apex
legends for the pre-show and I forgot that but it starts
like it was supposed to start at 3 10 but it got the show
got a little delayed because of the lining I was got also I
got really stressed out because I was like I know some of
you guys had another concert i was you tell me guys had the
hall live concert to go to as well so i was super stressed
out because i didn't want you guys to miss the hall live
concert just because you went to my concert so um so that
stressed me out as well because we're starting a bit late
and we didn't have everybody in yet so that was stressing me
out when i found out about it and then i was just like oh my
god i hope that we end in time so people are able to go to
the hall live concert as well because like like i said i
know like some people are doing are double dipping um today
so uh and i'm really thankful for you guys for coming to my
concert even though you already have tickets to the hololive
concert i'm really thankful everybody that went double
dipped today because i saw like a lot of holocaust plays
there as well i think i saw like i saw a bunch of like
hololive cause like they're going to mine and they go
straight to the hololive concert so they're like they went
in with the hololive cosplays to the concert as well so i'm
really thankful that uh i'm really glad I hope you guys made
it in time.
I hope you guys, I don't know if you guys made it in time,
but I hope you guys made it in time for the concert.
Because, uh, so, so, yeah.
Um, so had an Ian curse thing happen just a bit.
Oh, what happened there?
Um, oh, it's still going on.
So I, I, I, okay, you guys might not be watching right now.
it's the people who are at the hot live concert they uh uh i
don't know i hope you guys made it
so i'm there was that too that word that made me super
worried but yes there was like what else what else was there
that was stressing me there was like so many things that was
stressing me out talk about the technical difficulties um
but yeah oh yeah i start i started the stream an hour early
because i legitimately forgot about it and then but then
like while i was signing postcards when i was locked not in
the bathroom i was that was when i wasn't locked in the
bathroom but when i locked in the in one of my staff members
hotel rooms signing postcards uh my man you know when we
were having our great dog shirt meeting this was the by the
way while i was in the locked in the room we were also
having the dog shirt meeting while i was signing postcards
because i had to multitask all right In Jakarta, thank you,
Machinta Supa, thank you, thank you.
Perspect that today is the 4th of July.
Once again, Dragos fight to watch Dokey's birthday stories
live, and should they win the 4th of July will no longer be
an American holiday, but Dokey Day.
Today we celebrate Dokey Independence Day.
Thank you, the Super Machinta Supa, thank you, thank you.
I'm like dripping with sweat, even though it's over.
The day, like, the whole day is over.
I'm still, I'm still have, like, what's the word?
Like, the stresses, like, the...
when something like is overflowing like I still have the
overflow of stress still inside me so anyway while we're
having the meeting about the the dog shirt meeting my
manager was like by the way the tech people just mess me and
wondering why we are starting an hour early before the
stream and i was like um because the pre-show uh starts at
they told us the pre-show is supposed to start at 3 10 so i
want to be sure that people who have the streaming tickets
um can watch the pre-show and channel monet in my chat and
then he was just like oh okay no you know not questioning it
and then i was like tell them and then they didn't question
it and they were like oh okay and then they're like all
right we'll start it and then and I was just like um we told
the producers about this plan and why we are doing this plan
because we wanted to be sure the people who got the
streaming tickets can watch it and then talk about it in the
chat and that's why we're starting one hour early because I
want to make sure that the people who are watching in a
streaming ticket can also like talk about it in the chat and
then and then the the producer guy the other producer guy
was like yeah that's what she told us yeah that should be
the plan like so nobody questioned me nobody fact-checked me
be like um the pre-show wasn't in the streaming ticket isn't
in the streaming ticket so no the producer was in the group
chat too and so they're like she's the boss I guess like and
then because like I had so many I was signing postcards I
was signing postcards it was the post that dog shirt debate
and then it was the post dog shirt debate and and so we were
like so so then and then my manager brought up the fact was
like why why are we starting this an hour early doki and
then i was like me this is the pre-show that's why and then
30 30 minutes i think it was like 30 minutes before the
pre-show like i don't know it was like 15 minutes before the
pre-show was supposed to start uh by the way pre-show was
delayed like 10 minutes or something um 30 minutes start i
was like to my manager oh my god the pre-show isn't in the
streaming ticket why are we starting an hour early i did
that i was like wait a minute wait why are we starting an
hour that's it
And then my manager's like, we can't change it anymore,
Doki.
It's already too late.
When I was at the venue, I was like, wait, why are we making
everybody wait an hour to the stream?
Wait a minute.
But it was too late.
We couldn't change it anymore.
set it up if they had they set everything up for 2 30 and
then so i'm sorry for making you guys wait in the freaking
stream for an hour and 30 minutes still a freaking free
preview came on and so so i was like it's okay guys we're
all waiting the dragoons are waiting we're waiting he's
waiting okay so you got the real you get to feel what the
dragoons felt like when they were waiting waiting at the
venue lining up and waiting at the venue yeah like a real
concert you know it's for immersion exactly it was for
immersion guys
We're all in this together.
Anyway, yeah, you were in the chat line, exactly.
I've been thinking of Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you, congrats, and good job in the concert,
yokey.
Sadly, I couldn't be there live for this one, but I've had
to see another successful production down.
Also, I've been listening to Nami-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na.
I know that.
I told you yet.
You guys remember when I randomly sang 99 red balloons and
then I randomly sang it in German like all those months ago?
I don't remember when I sang that.
I just remember randomly I sang it in German too.
It was because of this.
It was because I was practicing for this concert.
Because I was trying to fucking sing in German.
I've been thinking of Super Chat, by the way.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, and then, so, I had a German friend record, like, did,
like, a slow read of my lines in German.
So, I could just fucking figure out how to fucking sing that
song in German.
Because it was like, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na,
na, na, na, na, na, na, na.
Oh, my gosh, I remember.
It's been so long since I sang it, too.
remember the lyrics for in german but he he was like he was
like helping he was like like like saying it really slow for
me so i could like figure out how to say the lyrics and
stuff and it was yeah i already forgot i'm i think i'm just
really tired i think if i wasn't really tired i could sing
it i could sing my lines in german um uh yeah and then we
that was my idea by the way.
Okay, originally it was supposed to, they were supposed to
drop if you guys didn't see on the streaming tickets, the
balloons were supposed to drop during the drop of it.
When we start, it was supposed to drop during, like, 99 red
balloons, like, the moment we sang that part, I think there
was a miscommunication.
It just dropped it the moment, like, the next set played.
But that was my idea, because I was like, when we sing red
balloons.
I wanted to have it drop during the actual drop.
So like it would have been, it would make more sense, you
know, like it was like 99 red balloons.
Yeah, but then they dropped it during the beginning of the
song.
Yeah, it dropped too early.
But like, that's fine.
Like, at least the idea was there.
I didn't want to be like, stop.
Like, you know,
I didn't want to be like, stop, stop, don't drop the
balloon.
Yeah.
And so, uh, it was too late already.
It stopped the con scene.
And then, you know, when, you know, people were like, why
are balloons dropping?
But it was supposed to drop during when we sing the line, 99
red balloons.
And I knew drop the balloons.
Um.
and so uh but then the balloons the balloons by the way had
if anyone guys kept the balloons the balloons had my logo on
it too um but it was uh um but yeah I thought it was a
really I hope people were able to actually see the concert
with the balloons fucking flying everywhere I don't know if
anyone knows at the concert if were the balloons too
distracting or was it fine because I wanted to be like, I
wanted to have like, you know, I thought it was a fun idea.
So I hope you guys are still able to watch the concert.
Even the balloons were like in your fucking face.
Like, it was, I don't know.
It was not.
I kept some of the balloons too.
Oh, it was.
They, no, they got a hundred balloons.
It was a, they, I remember they told me, they were like, we
just blew a hundred balloons.
Um, and, uh, we were like, we just got, uh, a hundred
balloons.
hundred balloons blown up do you want some of the extra ones
like one extra yeah 90 not 100 it was one too many yeah it
was a hundred balloons that got dropped um i think one
hundred or unlimited balloons that's i'm pretty sure it was
like the in case one balloon um that disappears that's fair
just in case um Recycling the magenta soup, but thank you.
Thanks for sharing the stressful happiness behind the
scenes.
Ended up, the team, and all the guests have done a really
good job in the concerts.
Complete a blast.
Please be proud of yourself.
Thank you, the magenta soup, but thank you.
Yeah, so it's basically unlimited.
99 were first edition.
The 100th was a reprint.
Someone took one of the balloons on a live concert.
that's really funny um um i'm glad i'm glad it turned out
great i was like like i'm really stressed out from i was so
stressed out but like i'm still feeling that stress what was
i talking before about before i talked about the 99 red
balloons what was i talking about before because i was
trying to recramp like everything that that like fucking um
made me crazy and that's the hundred balloon guys The
balloon went to the Hall of Live concert.
That's where it went.
So yeah, that part, and then obviously it was not fun to
have technical difficulties.
I asked, like, why that happened.
And they said, like, the main, one of the other producers,
because I'm one of the producers, too, because, and they
didn't know why like I should get like a recap of why that
happened too because like on the first day on the first day
everything went smoothly so I was like what happened why did
I was just like I was like and I was so like I was so
stressed out about it too I was literally like I was so I
was like I was so stressed out about that because obviously
I don't want you know I want this concert to live smoothly
so it like really stressed yeah it really stressed me out in
the beginning but I'm glad like it was just the beginning
part and after after that part everything was okay because I
was like this didn't happen the first day you know and it
was something out of my control too because there's nothing
I could do as well you know so it's like you know I that's
what makes me more mad and stressed out because it It was
like, out of my control.
Like, there was nothing I could do to stop that.
Because, like, I was like, that's why I was like, I asked
for, like, a report on how that happened.
So, like, at least, like, it would help me, it would soothe
my mind to know, like, what happened.
It's like, what happened?
Like, yeah.
Yeah.
So I was just like, yeah.
So, because, like, that's, like, one of the things I, I, I,
like, tried to control as much as I could.
So that was, like, one of the things that was just, like,
for me.
Yeah.
And also, like, you know, the live stream, um, going
offline, too.
Yeah, nothing worse than the unknown.
So it's just like, I don't know what else.
Also, I'm really sorry.
You know, the worst, okay, this was the worst part for me.
Um, not the worst.
I should know.
There were so many moments that was, like, freaking me out
and it was when uh when we were seeing when me and sachi
were saying feel good because feel good and i my opinion was
the best song in the entire set list also the map yeah yeah
so um feel good was the best song in the entire in my
opinion that i sang in the entire set list And apparently I
found out in the streaming ticket that there was a little
corruption going on there.
I don't know what happened.
I asked about it.
They don't know what happened as well.
And they said they would fix it.
They told me that it's going to be fixed.
And then also if you saw a cursor on the screen, that would
also be fine.
I didn't even know it was like I said.
I didn't know what was going on on the streaming ticket
side.
So yeah.
so yeah yeah so um that would also be fixed too because I
was like I was like how did all this happen and it happened
on day one too um I it didn't happen on day one so I was
just like like yeah was it oh was it on the I didn't notice
it too but I saw someone I saw I saw someone said it so I
was like what and I like I had to like message my manager in
between being like what's what's going on like yeah but it
will be fixed I was told that yeah I was told that uh um the
streaming ticket video uh will be fixed and i really hope so
because i think i think that's feel good was the best song
um that was in the concert i would like uh like when oh my
gosh when like i would re-listen to that song over and over
again because I really uh I I it was it was just really good
um speaking of and but despite everything what the fuck okay
despite everything um uh everything that happened in all of
it I'm glad everyone loved the concert because that was like
when did I I do this since February?
That was like four to five months of absolute hell.
That was actually four to five months.
There's so much.
Yeah, it was like since February.
I think it was like since February when we started the
planning for everything.
And I need you guys to know I'm apologize because everything
was put on what is it called was was delayed everything was
put on what's the word called when you're delaying something
um i'm cat i'm tired my brain is tired and you guys see me
in my dictionary right now
was put on the back burner yeah everything was put on the
back burner and put on hold including like my birthday
stuff, like everything because of this concert.
And I was, it was just, there's so much, there was so much
stuff going on.
And it was all put on hold to try to just make this concert
a reality.
And I'm glad.
I'm glad like like like people love the concert everyone was
excited every I heard and I saw so many photos and videos
like everyone like oh my gosh everyone did amazing the live
band was amazing like I know I just went on with like a
two-hour rent of how stressed I was but like in the end it
was all worth it for the final product of how you guys how
you guys um took the concert and like um took out of the
concert and giving you guys the experience that i wanted to
uh wanted you guys to experience and it was so cool seeing
the videos of how everyone was like just rocking out all
that's i told you guys i told you guys the set list was
going to be crazy I was remember when I said the one thing I
was most proud about this entire concert was the set list I
I personally picked majority of the songs I got the uh uh
the perms for it uh by the way Pokemon I for some reason
Pokemon had was okay to sing literally by the way Pokemon
was the last song I added to my set list because they were
like we're missing a song Doki and I've like I've already
like finalized everything and then it was like I had to
record it within like to record Pokemon um for like the song
itself uh within like four days so like oh no not even four
days it was like within three days because they were like we
need one more song for the set list to complete the the to
uh to complete like the full set yeah and then yeah so i had
to figure out a song in three days and then i was just like
because they're like we're we don't have enough songs like
we need one more and i was just like god
i was like Pokemon.
I don't know.
I was like, Pokemon.
Yeah.
Yeah, so.
Oh, my yeah.
Why were the back vocals were very...
There were supposed to be back vocals.
I think it was just a balancing thing.
Because, like...
Wait, let me see.
I can...
Let me see.
I don't even think I can show it.
no I don't non this they there is because I'm worried if I
fucking play like two seconds of that
claim yeah they're I think I think the plan also for the
other producers was that they wanted the audience to also
sing along to it so yeah I don't yeah yeah so I think that
was the plan they wanted the audience as well to sing along
to the Pokemon yeah so I think that's why they tune the
backing vocals down as well because I it was louder in the
demo that was sent
um let me blow my nose real quick
but yeah like oh my gosh the fact that pokemon was like the
last minute addition to to the whole thing was fucking like
drove me insane yeah yeah i think that was the intent as
well yeah so um uh where was i what else was it uh But like,
yeah, the set list was, I think the one song that wasn't
specifically chosen by me was from, was Duby's song, 99 Red
Balloons.
She picked 99 Red Balloons and thank God we had the perms
for it.
Thank God.
That's all that matters.
Thank fucking God.
perms for 99 red balloons because that was the song that she
picked that she really wanted to do um yeah i didn't yeah so
but so i checked it and i was like we can do it yeah she did
yeah no she did her like when we had the uh when we sang the
german part because the song she picked was from I remember
the band um they do they sang it they sang it in German in
the middle of it and she also sang it in German yeah uh yeah
because I she was like she was like did you see because I um
I was singing in German and then she was like wait are you
singing in German and I was like yeah that's the original
song and she's like oh she's like oh I didn't realize we're
gonna do
So I was like, well, it's too late.
I already fucking learned German.
Like, I already fucking learned the German part, Duvee.
We're going in.
Like, it's too late to back out.
I'm not wasting my German experience here.
She was like, what are we just saying in England?
I was like, it's too late.
I already learned German.
Yeah.
we're already in too deep we're in too deep we're in too
deep yeah so yeah so that's like that's like yeah i'm not
wasting my fucking germ like i'm not wasting using my german
friend to fucking enunciate every all the german words in
0.5 speed while i try to learn this is there a set I'll tell
you the set list right now.
I'm doing it by memory, by the way, guys.
I might not know the exact names of the songs, but we
started off with, it was Skater Boy.
Every time we touch.
Because every time we touch, I get ecstatic.
This is when I start emoting on you guys.
This is when we started emoting.
um uh it was something i i wanted to do but it was like i
was like okay when we have that segment where we're starting
to dance i want to do i want to start doing fortnite dances
i would start doing fortnite evil i was like when we're
doing this for our choreo we are gonna fortnite emo
um uh uh what else do we okay it was every time we touch and
then technologic uh that one was the one of the hardest
songs because i had to do it in like some verses i had to do
in one breath and i was just like By the way, I hand-picked
which model, which 3D model, and what, you might see that,
like, Sir Alt Doki, by the way, you guys, like, the two, I
told you guys, I told you guys it was worth it.
You guys were like, why did you get two new models?
And I was like, no, you guys don't understand, it's worth
the experience.
Like, like, don't, no, it's, like, it will, it will make
sense.
It will make sense in the concert.
like i was gonna say it will make but like i hand picked
which song will go for which 3d model and then you if you
watch back the stream streaming tickets you can see how like
alt doki and like um skate uh skater i guess i guess punk
rock doki i'll call her punk rock doki because we already
have skater doki because she's actually a skater girl uh
punk rock doki had different alternatives to their outfits
because like each both outfits had different combinations or
different what's it called different outfit combinations to
it so you'll you might notice it and that was me being very
specific on what each model is wearing during which song so
it would match the song itself so you might see alt Doki
having glasses on with a thousand miles and then like the
shirt on or like the shirt off or something like that so it
was all everything was very carefully crafted in my like
that's why i say it was four months of hell it was like
yes yes i i was very particular in exactly what i want and
how i wanted it to look like so i was very uh i paid i did a
very a lot because that's what i'm saying when i I'm very
stressed out when things are out of my control because like
I I am very I'm a very detail-oriented person when it comes
to like my artistic vision and everything and so it like
when I can't control it especially with the technical
difficulties it stresses me out so much because it I was
like it was something out of my control and I was like I've
worked so hard
I'm just like, ah, we all worked so hard, but I'm like, oh,
I want to make sure like everything looks, I just want to
give you guys the best experience too, so I'm still happy
even despite the scuffness of everything, um, not
everything, sorry, even though the scuffness at the
beginning, um, everyone still had a great time, and everyone
still enjoyed themselves too, um, and like, it like overcame
the scuffness yeah like so yeah okay sorry back to the set
list but back to the back to the set list uh yeah dokey
dokey rewind um it was our uh uh skater boy i mean of course
we start off with a classic
um Let's see, and then it was, every time we touch,
technologic, thousand miles, did we go to, actually, do I
remember from the top of my head?
I'm like, now I'm self-dutting myself.
Maybe I don't remember this on the top of my head.
let me see let me see i know like they posted a set list a
while ago
uh okay which one is it all right don't worry guys i'll get
you our set list guys all right oh i found it wait did i
find it all right jump is this still the present
because i'm trying to find it
i'm trying to remember i'm like what's chibi-doki next after
i'm trying to find it where's the set list is this all right
let me look at this okay no that is not the set list i was
just an order of all the songs we've done all right is it
this is this all right there you go all right it was i have
the full set list right now um okay skater boy every time we
touch technologic a thousand miles bob to top that was my
suggestion by the way we won okay for those who didn't watch
before our original plan was that we wanted to do um the the
puss and boost and donkey song uh viva be the loka
Viva Valita Loka We wanted to do that song Because we I
wanted I don't know Who was going to be Puss and who was
going to be Maybe Cheeby was going to be Donkey And I was
going to be Puss in boots But like We wanted to do Living
the Vita Loka Shrek Edition But we didn't get the perms for
it We didn't get the perms for that So then I was like
Cheeby what if we do bop to the top because there's some
espanol in that song but we're like but we do the we do the
twins version i remember what's her name ryan and who and uh
what's what are their names sharpay ryan and sharpay We do
the Ryan and Sharpay version because I felt like that would
fit us more.
And I was very specific.
I was like, when we do the choreo for Bob to the top, it has
to be exactly like the original music, like the original
performance from Ryan and Sharpay.
So if you re-watch that vibe and then you play the original
high school musical from Ryan and Sharpe My moves are almost
exactly like the duet song Yeah Yeah So except we didn't get
a ladder We didn't we did not get a ladder So you might
notice Some of the choreo was from that exact like scene
from the show from the movie yeah same with a thousand miles
if you watch back a thousand miles you will see some scenes
was inspired by white chicks so you know when emily and i
were like and i need you and i want you I was like we have
to make a reference to white chicks with Terry Cruz so
that's if you rewatch the VOD and I need you and the opening
line for it was literally I the opening line for it like the
ad lib the ad lib was literally was like oh my god how did
you know I love this song
yeah so um so I literally quoted that movie because when I
was like I want to do a thousand miles because I gave her a
list of songs that I want to do and I had her pick from that
list and she was like I want to do a thousand miles for the
list I gave her and then I was like we have to I was like if
we're doing a thousand miles we have to make reference to
white chicks like so I told you I was it was very attention
to detail like i wanted to reference all the stuff that
people grew up with like there's nostalgia of it like all
the old school like all the memes and stuff and um and like
like just references to things that we all grew up with or
like we all know about versus in the meme like back the
memes back then and um just like the funny moments and then
just like have like it's like nostalgia overload type deal
yeah yeah so i wanted to nostalgia bait all of all of you
guys uh mike thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you oh yeah i do remind i should advertise the streaming
tickets real quick um let's see what was the spawn but yeah
i'm sorry that i'm so sad i feel good lagged out there uh in
the streaming ticket like in person it wasn't lagging
obviously if you're watching it in person it was not like i
would hope
um let me see if i can pull pull up the link to the
streaming ticket oh my god i tweeted so much about i tweeted
more about merch than streaming i should tweet it more about
the streaming i'm sorry guys i i was like merch merch i'm
like scrolling where the fuck are the streaming tickets okay
it was the last okay I tweeted I tweeted so much in the last
week guys I just realized I tweeted so much on the last week
okay yeah but it will be fixed I'm just sad that um like I
said I'm sad that like uh that happened for the people who
are watching the streaming tickets because uh um because i
in my opinion i felt that was the best song that was in the
entire set set list that we sang um like all the songs i
sang i felt like feel good uh the field uh feel good was the
best i think the rap part was my favorite um the rap part
and it's like Windmill, windmill, banana.
Like when Shachi and I harmonized that one.
I felt was really good.
I like their harmonization.
Banana, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na,
na, na, na, na, okay.
concert merch all right here you go i'll replace that uh
what else was i saying uh oh yeah after bob to the top it
was ppap pen pineapple apple pen and then uh running in the
running in the 90s um it was that um the original the
original one um so uh we were originally going to have chibi
was supposed to do a duet for country roads but it had to be
dropped from the set list because the person that she was
going to do it to with um had something came up so then she
had to replace it with a solo song so uh it which is why you
might notice on the encore that it was just me and Mimi and
Amali weren't in the encore but that was because when
Chibi's guest had to couldn't do it because something came
up came up for them um something came up with that for them
um and it was just uh so I had to find like
guest so so I asked Amelie and Nimi if they could come in
even though it was like really late into the concert prep
and I really appreciate Amelie and Nimi for like you know
giving your time to be part of my concert because it was
such a last minute edition as well and uh and they were able
to do it and I'm really thankful for that because like uh
because obviously you know it was minute thing and they have
to like get everything done with like super like in a really
tight deadline too and everything so I really appreciate it
too because like they helped they helped it me a lot for
there and that's why you didn't see them in the encore as
well because at that point we like it was too late to add
them to the encore so because the encore was like supposed
to be all of us you being like yeah um so if you guys were
like oh where's uh nimi anomaly um that's why they weren't
in the encore because at that point it was like or we
couldn't add them into the encore anymore because it was
like already like a lot of people too yeah so but like i
hope you guys still like the encore like i was like we have
to end with this song like uh i was like we have to end with
not tragedies and i wanted to be everyone at first okay by
the way it was that because that was like a classic
throwback song you know it was like it's like a classic uh
emo goth song uh and and like everyone used to sing it back
then and it was such a meme to closing the goddamn door like
every and i was like we have to end with that but by the way
that song was almost gonna be high school music.
It was almost going to be, we're all in this together.
It was between the encore, it was between, we're all in this
together.
But no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I don't know.
And I was just like, yeah, I was just like, okay, it's
either that, or I write Sinzani imagining.
I'm glad that you, what could have been, yeah.
Because I could only pick one for the encore, because like I
said, like, it, we, it was really hard to also get everybody
together, too.
for it like yeah yeah so so it was like i felt like because
of the whole theme of the concert and i was like we already
have bop to the top you know i was just like we already have
bop to the top so i was like we already have a high school
musical song so i was like we don't have um how we don't do
i have another one no we don't right we don't have another
panic at the song so I was just like what we have to do
there'll be a repeat so then I was just like okay we don't
have panic of disco so we're gonna end with Irish sins not
tragedies because they were both very they were both like
good ending songs because good ending songs that everyone
knows you know they're all like good ending songs that
everyone knows so I was just like which one do I do like
yeah yeah so um yeah so that's why we went with irish's not
strategies in the end but anyway so um pineapple pine
pineapple uh apple pen and then running in the was it
running in the 90s or running oh yeah matara was like
jamming the fuck up for running in the 90s because I um
during like chibi set I went to like um I saw her and she
was just like like she was just like rocking the fuck out to
running in the 90s yeah
and after that was um caramel dancing this one was I got the
perms for caramel dancing but chibi was the one that really
that picked it out of like like i said i got a huge list of
perms we're like songs that i really want to do and then she
like i picked bob to the top and she picked caramel dancing
uh we're we sang the english version because i was not
learning another language uh you guys know the reason why i
made this theme is so i could sing in english by the way
guys i was just like i i wanted to sing in english because i
feel like uh that's not something
you know because like i feel like a lot of concerts uh
especially vtuber concerts is a lot of like because it's
easier to get perms for japanese songs versus english songs
um so and um so it's easier to get perms for foreign
language songs than it is for english songs so uh so this is
what one of the biggest reasons why i did this theme because
i wanted people to sing along and be able songs that they uh
that they grew up with and stuff like that so this is one of
the main reasons why I picked uh like why I made it like a
uh made it like an English like almost fully English set
list too because I felt like it definitely enhanced the
experience of the concert as well as those who were there in
the venue as well um it was it was fun to see too it was
like a mixture of Like, it was like an idle rock concert.
If you guys were there at the venue, it was, uh, it was,
like I said, it was an idle rock concert because people
still had the pen lights and everything, but it still had
that rock vibe going in.
Yeah, so I thought it was really cool.
Anyway, after Caramel Dancing, it was the Pokemon theme
song.
Um, and then feel good.
Thanks for the memories.
me maybe wannabe with the sloppy sisters oh tell you what oh
it was so funny because um snuffy accidentally said the
wrong line for wannabe because it was you know how we're
like huh huh huh and then she was like it was like she ended
it and we were like it was like huh Ha, ha, hey.
Yeah.
And then I didn't notice it because I was just, like, so
busy and didn't realize she was like, hey.
That's...
Yeah, but then we're, like, stuffy.
Stuffy is ha.
And she's like, oh.
No, no, it's not the final concept.
But during, like, the rehearsal stuff, she kept saying, And
I didn't realize it because I was so fucking stressed out
and busy because I couldn't And then she's just we're like,
ha ha ha hey But I didn't I didn't realize it for the
longest time And I think it was like a month before A month
before the concert I was like I was re-listening to like the
demos And I was like, Sophie, why are you saying hey?
I was like, she's like, I thought we were supposed to say A.
I was like, we're all saying hi.
Um, when I'm back from, I want, I want back in Canada, I'll
show you guys, like, I'll show you guys the hate.
I'll show it to you guys.
I'll let you guys listen to the, the, the demos.
It's really funny.
Because she did A for the, for all of it too yeah and it was
really funny um but i was at that time i was panicking
because like um because i i was just like we gotta fix this
like space thank you the akasupa thank you thank you happy
birthday doki i never been to moshpink until someone flew
into me today but now i know your cellars are freaking
amazing the badass man all the girls too first time seeing
you perform live and everyone else as well i hope it's not
the last thank you the akasupa thank you thank Thank you.
I'm glad you enjoyed the concert.
The live event went fucking insane.
I saw like, you know, I saw them shredding.
I saw the drummer drumming.
I don't know.
Sorry, I don't know like the correct term.
I saw them shredding and drumming and going hard on
pineapple, pineapple, pen pineapple, apple pen.
But anyway, after that, after wannabe, um i felt like that
was such a perfect we wanted to do wannabe for the longest
time by the way uh the sloppy sisters talked about one like
um before we did before we settled on the sonic song i'm
sorry i don't remember the title of the song at the top of
my head but um the sonic song cover that we did for my last
concert um wannabe was uh was in the running
from the city yeah it's either between escape from the city
or wannabe and we went with escape from the city and then
during for this concert it was going to be space jam because
i i thought like you know i thought it would be really funny
if we did space jam we like come on and stab and welcome
come on and jab and welcome to the slab yeah and then we do
like basketball choreo and stuff we were like what if it's
like basketball choreo from high school musical you know and
we thought that was really funny but we couldn't get the
purse for space jam like last minute at first they were like
we can do space jam and then later on they were like oh we
can't do space jam so it was like it wasn't like last last
minute but like um i thought the set list was finalized
until they were like oh you gotta change uh space jam and
then i talked to girls i was like just let's just do one and
be guys i feel like i feel like you know i we we're
literally it's we have the same amount of do we have the
same amount of girls as sister four it's the spice girls
yeah yeah i'm just thinking do we is the spice girls four
girls i don't remember all the spices i'm missing one okay
so it's almost all the girls yeah there's i forgot all the
spices guys I so anyway um and the harmonies went fucking
hard too the harmonies went hard so like I'm happy I'm so
happy how it came out and then after one of me I was like
non-line red blues
um the choreo for that I was also very particular about how
the choreo what should look like and everything like what I
wanted in the choreo I wanted to involve the set you can see
that we had like the little boom box stereo thing and we're
like standing on it we wanted to have like a mic stand as
well like similar to the um similar to the uh um to original
music video where uh the guy was grabbing onto the mic stand
and just like kicking it and like doing a bunch of stuff but
apparently tracking for that is really really hard so then
we're like okay we'll just have a stereo and we're like
standing on it and be like yeah like yeah fuck fuck the
government like yeah tear down that wall yeah you know um it
is based off for those who didn't know 99 red balloons was
based off the uh sorry it's an app sorry i'm guys i'm tired
I have one hour left for my birthday You can, you can You
can, I'm actually meet in an hour You guys, it's still my
birthday So like, yeah, anarchy Like, you know, like,
because it's the song You guys didn't know 99 Red Balloons
Is Based off of The tearing down of the Berlin Wall So I
wanted to, like, have that, like, Energy going into it Um
And, uh, and like that was like my thought going into it too
so i loved like how it looked in the end as well because it
was all about like you know like yeah fuck yeah and then
obviously we end on irish's not tragedies and that was the
entire set list of everything uh yeah it was just it was a
crazy
yeah it was the entire concert was was a lot
oh best of both worlds sorry i skipped best of both worlds
99 red balloons and also best of both worlds i realized
sorry um best of both worlds so I had to include Hannah
Montana song in there, you know, obviously, uh, and then we
had twice the amount of dokees there.
Yeah, yes, it was the best of both worlds.
I was like, we have to, I was like, oh my God, if we do best
of both worlds, I can use both dokees.
I can use old girl doke and, um, bounty hunter doke, like,
you know, retro doke and bounty hunter doke.
And then I thought you're harmonizing I'm harmonizing with
myself but yeah the double D's I was literally like singing
with like oh my god what an ego I'm like harmonizing my with
myself and singing with myself yeah so the original line was
what's it what was it you know I was like is that Kenny
Omega so originally you know how like in Hannah Montana best
of both worlds it's like who is he who did she say I don't
remember who she said so i had to name a celebrity so i was
just like i have to have like similar syllables so i was
just like kenny omega
i don't remember who the original celebrity was for the
fucking song so that was like that was what he said kenny
omega because i needed like have similar syllables and yeah
and like and that it would roll off the tongue just like the
because i it was like some other random celebrity and i was
just like well i should make a reference to someone that
like we talk about so so so that was why i was just i just i
randomly he wasn't there by the way kenny omega was not was
not actually there so i just like it was just me trying to
make a reference to to like um like just make a making a
reference where you're like i know that guy yeah but what if
he was the dokey
yeah kenny was the other dokey by the way but which one
um so you painted us i thought kenny was mega was in the
show um um I think oh yeah and then there's also you listen
to wannabe because someone was like oh mint ad lib the dokey
bird in sins if you listen to wannabe when we're doing like
call outs and stuff uh we changed it to our names um we yeah
we changed the call out like sing rap uh to talk about each
other So, it's just, you know, it's the little details, you
know, the little ad-lips and stuff.
Yeah, also, oh yeah, okay, I'll show you guys the, I don't
remember who made the outfits.
I know some of you guys, you're like, the outfits, the
outfits.
So, I'll show more about this when I'm back from Canada.
a lot um i'm trying to remember the artist right now i
didn't write it's not on this laptop because um it's not on
this laptop because uh because like i said i don't have any
i i thought i had time but back okay back in canada i'm
sorry guys i still have like 57 more minutes left for you
guys to bully me until you guys can it's still my birthday
so I can I still have the no bully privilege you can see it
all you want when my birthday is over guys just give me a
give me like 50 56 more give me 56 more minutes guys and
then you can go fucking wild and say everything you want to
say all right okay so huge shout out to guys do you guys
remember the artist who did uh get and stream one minute
before your birthday ends did somebody say birthday bullying
next thing thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
okay so um do you guys remember okay of course I mean who
wouldn't forget the girlfriend cover so the person who
designed the girl who drew the artwork for the girlfriend
cover designed the outfit for for the punk rock doki so I'll
show you the 3d of it so I need you guys to know we went
through a lot of like a lot of design changes for it like
design concepts for it because like I said I was very very
particular with how this looked like and I went through so
many corrections so this is the end result of it so now you
guys can see why because this outfit came first um this was
before the key visual so that's why like in the key visual
um i didn't want to go with a similar theme because um in
the key visual i didn't want it to look like the key visual
uh because i wanted to have a different theme to it as well
so uh me thank you the magenta soup but thank you thank you
wishes you a happy birthday toky thank you thank you the
agenda soup I think also real quick I need to charge my
phone now whoops all right give me a sec I had to charge my
phone so now it's okay um so that's why when I when I was
showing you the concept art of the key visual I was like oh
I like this but I can't have that because my 3d model um was
already gonna have something similar to that and I wanted
oops I wanted um I wanted it to uh look have a different
theme to the uh to the 3d model as well so I had to took out
so I had to take elements that I felt was too similar to the
3d model um out of the key visual because I want like I said
I wanted it to I wanted to each model like like each design
for these outfits to be different and in its own theme as
well so you can see like um all the stuff for it it's hey
hey it's the girlfriend and in the pants everywhere you guys
this is very heavily I will say this fashion for this one
for punk rock um this is very heavily inspired I sent like
so many Avril Lavigne outfits you can tell you can tell that
this is heavily heavily inspired by abriel levine so i said
so many outfits that she wore yeah yeah also i can take off
the tank top and or uh or the shirt and it reveals like a
tank top underneath as well so um i'll show you even like in
the pants too so let me see I know I said I'll show the
concept art later but I'll show you some of it now uh I'll
show you guys some of it so I'll show you guys the reference
sheet too uh like I said like uh in the concert you can tell
that I had different outfit combinations um for each song
because i wanted it to be like um i wanted it to be like
each outfit matches like the song that i'm singing so let me
show you so this is the without without the shirt and i have
a little dragoon a little layers on too so like i have
another layer underneath the tank top too yeah
non-goon gets nothing no we'll have build a goon don't worry
so here's like the references uh to it but originally um we
had a council for this because I was, we were, I had a
council and then, um, I voted against the council.
I didn't, we had, just so you know, we had a council that
wanted something differently entirely.
And I was like, the council's wrong.
So it was made of mods and staff members and the mods and
staff members really really wanted i'll show you this was
our first concept so this was our very first concept all
right that was said you can tell there are so many i love
the final piece uh to keep my degree to mad i am the council
now have birthday from argentina i'm not very good uh with
english but so i understand 70 but i like your accent even
super chat think you think 70 is enough context so the
council really really really wanted the shorts and i was
like the council's wrong i know it was it was the shorts
they wanted design one really really really badly and I was
like the council's wrong I didn't see why they wanted you
because I because I was like that's not Afro-Levin the
council got too greedy you guys got it you know see if the
council was more subtle and like if the The council was more
subtle and with what they wanted and eased their way into
the decision.
I'm a short slumber, but the council was, Ron.
The long pants are correct.
Nexi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
They were pushing so hard for the shorts.
I was like, no.
so this is the original concept right and i was like
struggling really hard because um i was like this is not it
like i feel like we needed like i don't know it just didn't
feel very avril levine you know that's like that's basically
it i was like this doesn't feel very avril levine to me So I
was like, we needed, like I said, I sent it in more, more
Avril Levine outfits.
I'm a Canadian punk princess.
Why are you not, what are you not understanding?
Papa's spirit.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So then this was like take two after I sent in a thousand
Avril Levine fashion outfits and being like, like 2000s core
fashion and like what she wears and what was punk like, pop
skater punk like and so this was the second uh concept art I
was sent so um and then I did I was like debating really
hard because the dad hat was really really cute and I was
just like I was like I I almost went with it and then you
know the the skater jorts too and everything but the one
thing i really like was just like the the sweater on the on
the hips because i felt like i was very like you know back
in the day people loved wearing like those sweater capes or
whatever the fuck it's called like i know like the hat but
then i was like i really wanted to show like the hair cut a
bit more so like the hat would cover that so um so we didn't
go with and all Also, the reason why I didn't go with a hat
was, I think it was because, wait, was it, let me look at it
real quick.
Also, one of the reasons why I didn't go with a hat was
because Chibi-Doki was wearing a similar hat for a key
visual.
So I didn't want that to, I didn't want that to conflict.
Yeah, the tie-in jacket, sorry, the waist jacket thing,
sorry, the waist jacket.
know what i said before so that's why i didn't pick the hat
because um because it already looked too much like an
overlap with chibi's uh key visual so i didn't want to like
i wanted i wanted to be different from like because i said
like even i would try to make the key visual different from
um from the 3d model because i wanted each one to have its
own thing um yeah so uh So that was like concept number two.
And you see we were also playing around with hair clips as
well.
Because I was like, oh, what do we do with the hair too?
Anyway, so this one was like us playing around.
Yeah, I just wanted it to be...
I like how...
I want each outfit to be its unique...
Like, you know, because it's like another Doki to the
Dokiverse.
So I wanted each outfit to be like its own...
You can see it being its own thing as well.
And there's no like overlap to anything.
So like each theme.
So instead of us playing around with clip design, with the,
you know, the paper clip, hair clip, the stars, just like
normal clips and everything, are you a man or a girl?
Well, my dad was a man and my mom was a girl, so I mixed.
Like you love that quote.
anyway uh that checks out showed up to my boy holland that
man can fucking cook memes
so uh and then here's like a more detailed like hair design
too so you can tell like the back yeah holland said that you
got like he had the same question and he's like he said the
same the exact thing i was like oh my god i wish i came up
with that i i was just like man i wish i came up with that
he's so yeah anyway anyway so then i got the count like at
was just me designing it and then i got the council i i
gathered back the council i don't know why the council has
not been this bad yet and guess what's what was picked out
of all three of these
anyway so the council tried so hard yet again to get their
industry plant in
came back and the council uh really was they were fighting
so hard for the shorts but i said fuck i gathered the
council for the vote and then i was like fuck your vote it
doesn't matter i'm going with three i think three was the
one that was least voted i mean it was it was yeah Like, we
had a dad as an appeal.
Like, but look, Doki, what if dad was there?
Yeah, so...
Anyway, I gathered the council again just to tell them their
votes don't fucking matter.
And this isn't a democracy.
And then I went with three, which was not what the council
voted.
your vote means nothing yeah so there was no point in voting
at all like they were i was like i was told my manager i was
like um um uh bring the council back reestablish the council
i need help and they all voted for the shirts i was like
disband the council they're useless like sorry you're not
useless council you're not You're not used much.
You're not useless.
I'm just singing.
I'm just singing shorts was not it
The shorts was not in the shorts the shorts was not in You
were it was a ceremonial thing Yeah So um so the council has
failed the test um also we were experimenting with shoes.
I don't know noticed that but um we're also experimenting uh
with shoes as well so we're like doing converse and like
boots and sneakers and everything and then i think we
settled yeah we settled oh yeah and then there's shirt
designs too i respect your opinion but not
hmm and then let me see um and then here are the different
shirt designs as well like i said we went through so many
designs because i was very i'm very very anal in particular
about like concept and like just concept conception like i
don't know i'm just i'm such a perfectionist when it comes
to this i i i think about so many different like facts like
features and stuff that i want so we're talking about like
um different shirts that we want to do and then I and like
there these were all the ideas and stuff but in the end I
went with the original idea that we have with the just sort
of fun of me doing them I'm like I'm like a miracle we have
one veto per year but I have a veto like I have a v like one
veto per in the UN but I have one I have one veto every
second um so we had all these designs but i felt like it was
just way too complicated so i felt all these shirts designs
were just way too complicated so we went back to the
original concept which was the the girlfriend shirt uh with
the hey hey you but that said to add the um i was just like
we had to add the uh the uh the tank the tank top too with
um with the skull design so I felt like that was a good
feature in the end as well and then you can see this is our
one of the other concepts the next concept stage so we fully
deleted the shorts and the paper then we went with the paper
clips and here so the shorts are gone the shirts are they're
not coming back they're
like the shirt it was just the shorts are not like like it's
like the dress code if you're if you put your hands down and
your pants is uh above your fingertips uh we're sending you
back home like yeah it's god so so we were trying to decide
the pants and you guys can tell like which one i ended up
picking um
let's see and in the end we went we went with this design I
don't even know why I'm saving again because it's like
literally it's like and in the end this was our final design
oh and there's a little star star makeup on the left eye
it's so yeah so this was like my Avril Levine inspired with
the tie and everything too because like she would wear like
ties and stuff with her outfits too and the Avril Levine
inspired punk rock outfit which I thought was perfect yeah
so this this is how it came out to be I'm happy with how I'm
happy with I'm happy with how it turned out.
speaking of that, speaking of the concert, I am allowed to
post two songs from the concert outside of the free
streaming preview.
So the free stream people, it's going to be up for that.
I was thinking if I should trim it, so it's just, should I
trim it, or should I just keep it in?
Fucking, you guys gotta fast forward to that part where it
starts.
So I'm allowed to post two performances from the concert i
want one of them to be feel good but i don't know which one
would be the other one so i need help with that because it's
very very very hard to decide i don't know i don't know i
love like all the other performances were so good too so um
i need you guys help for which one to do um which one are
your favorites guys also let me i need to get my tissue
because I'm gonna blow my nose again I'll be back
I am back I'm back well technologic is already a part of the
free stream preview so you can literally just watch it now
so we have to decide which one to do I don't know what the
second song could be though i don't know they're all good
that's the thing they're all so good it's so hard to pick i
see 99 red balloons we'll do a vote we'll bring back the
council we'll bring back the council again 99 red balloons
uh caramel i'm sorry if i spell it wrong guys and okay one
of me all right we can have one more i cannot be bothered to
spell check it right now i'm too tired video incoming
all right and then all right so it's not tragedy all right
all right guys but i'm gonna eat my cake with my fingers
it's such a big cake too that's the worst part toky stop
eating cake with your fingers oh this is my supposed to eat
i have no heart
cake.
I did wash my hands.
This is my birthday.
I still have an hour left.
I have four.
No, I have 40.
There's five minutes left.
Can't tell me what to do with my birthday.
Okay, guys.
The worst part of all of this is that I have, I have this
cake and I'm only going to have this cake for one day
because i'm supposed to eat this cake by myself like um
because they're like um initial
plan was to give this cake to people in the audiences but
then like we were worried i think we were worried that it
might be a health con like if anything happens to you guys
if you ate our cake it's gonna be on me
it's gonna be on us that so they're like dokey do you want
you want to take this cake back your hotel room I'm like all
right yeah yeah yeah so anyway so I'm eating this cake by
myself cuz like we had to leave the venue so fast like
within I think like within 30 to 40 minutes like everyone
has to leave the venue um i assume they had another show or
something um later on so um they were like you gotta go you
gotta go so we were like chop chop so everyone was gone
within like 30 to 40 minutes yeah like everybody go wash
your hands
i'm gonna take a bath after this i'm gonna enjoy it i'm
gonna enjoy today i'm cold I'm gonna enjoy I'm cold I'm so
cold right now
I think they enjoy it thank you guys thank you well it seems
like I write sins not well there's only I'll go out well
I'll start I'll end the vote when it's a thousand votes.
I don't even know if we're going to get there, but maybe if
we get there, I'll end it there.
I'm trying to think what else is there to talk about from
the concert.
I'm going back to...
Oh, wait, no, I'm going to spoil it, but I have some stuff I
plan to do.
Well, I'll tell you guys the story when I'm back in Canada.
at least have some stories to tell.
I have some plans when I'm in LA.
Are you spoiled a lot?
I don't even know what I spoiled, honestly.
I'm freaking so tired.
I've been awake since 7 in the morning.
I don't even know if I want to eat, like, another meal
today.
Because I only ate...
Oh, the tacos were so good.
Wait, let me say...
Okay, I'm going to be...
Let me say I can send photos.
photos that I take um oh yeah I took photo of the cake the
cake that I fucking am trying to eat with my fingers right
now let's see trying to see what I can show you guys I
already posted a lot of the pictures I took on Twitter um
yeah but then they'll be mad at me if you guys ate the
liability cake
I don't want you guys to be mad at me for me to lie I
believe you cake
oh yeah okay oh my gosh I forgot to mention this but it was
so sweet um I didn't realize about flower stand stuff so um
uh we were told that like we're accepting flower stands um
but uh we were saying like hey does Doki have a flower stand
coming in because we're getting flower stands for your other
guests and it was like we're um we found out about that like
like two days before the concert and then uh my staff was
like flower stands and then um my staff bought me a flower
stand because they felt they were like oh we don't want you
to feel left out so we're going to get you a flower stand
Doki and I thought I was really really sweet so that my my
got me um a flower stand because like I don't like flower
stand is very like uh an idol thing um and I don't do a lot
of idol concerts too so like I didn't know much about it but
like so my staff was like don't worry don't get your flower
stand um so at least like um so like uh it so I won't feel
left out and everything that was super sweet yeah did you
guys see it I got uh they said i mean there's like uh uh i
mean i took a photo of it and i was like i was like which
one's mine and then she was like the one that's yellow it's
fucking i was like which one's my flowers
That's so sweet.
I don't know if you guys saw my flower stand.
It was really...
Yeah, you're so cute.
The one that...
Yeah, I mean, it could be doofy.
I say as the other...
Does the doofy flower stand has the fucking doofy holding
it?
Like, it has a giant doofy holding the flowers.
Like, are you blind or color blind?
So...
That's a quote.
good affectionate yeah oh okay um we only got notification
that flower stand was yeah yeah so i don't like especially
for like um like idl v like i guess not idl vtubers who do a
lot of concerts like a flower stand is very uh i didn't even
know about it i was just like i didn't know like the i guess
like because i don't sing a lot you know i think i improved
a lot in singing though i think i hope i do i hope i
improved um like i feel like this year was my idol journey i
don't want to say idol because like i feel like i'm very
unlike on idol like i'm to be the ones that they throw
tomatoes at like um i feel like i i i say this year's been
my singing arc every year i'm on a different arc and this i
don't even know i don't remember what last year's arc was
but this year this year oh last year might have been just
been my gaming arc this year is my singing arc for sure
because i feel like i've done a lot of singing stuff already
um and here you're right in below zero thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you um
yeah i think but yeah this this years definitely oh yeah my
staff was like my manager was like so did you open the store
by the way i feel so bad i'm so sorry if you're watching
this manager i'm so sorry you worked so hard on the store
and everything and then i'm like jk i'm not gonna do it
today i'm not gonna shout out drop my outfit today i'm too i
can't do that right now i'm too tired Oh my god, my other
staff is like, I'm at midnight mahjong.
Oh my god, they're at midnight mahjong right now.
My European manager just woke up and my other staff member
that was, that other staff member was like, I'm at midnight
mahjong.
No beat juice yet.
is it not just mahjong what else do they wait they're not
even playing mahjong i see someone fucking playing a
fighting game wait what is midnight mahjong what the fuck
did not even they're not even playing mahjong what even
is this about wait is this like is this like what's the
other one what was the Fatima one with it's just a metaphor
wait I want to go to midnight what if I go to midnight
matchup Jason they go the Akasupa they get thank you happy
birthday dokey thanks for the last of the panel in the
concert they go the Akasupa they get thank you which is mine
John oh it's just a gaming gathering outside oh wait is it
is it just a land party and it's just going this is this
just a land party right now oh it is wait everyone they're
having I literally see tech wait what is that is that is
that street fighter I can't tell I see someone with UV
Where do I go to Midnight Mongeau?
The night is young.
It's not midnight yet.
But what do you do at midnight?
My John.
This is like actual.
No one knows what happens when it's midnight.
You can head down at midnight and it can truly be midnight.
It's not.
They're like, it's not midnight yet.
you blame that that's why that's true that's true holocaust
right delays apparently so a bunch of people not making it
here yet oh my god it's gonna get fucking wild it's gonna
get sick as hell it's gonna go crazy they're all waiting for
the holocaust to end to start the majeung they're all the
moment that concert ends apparently it's still going on yeah
it's gonna be wild holy shit how delayed is it it's like 11
my shock after dark yeah wait is it done now oh oh there oh
it's done now it oh it just also like people are just
heading there now oh my god wait wait how far
midnight majean takeover oh wait my manager is watching
hello i'm sorry i didn't i didn't do the store after you
worked so hard i didn't you want to talk about it by the way
my manager was the one that made started and ended the
stream and also was the one was like what what happened to
the stream why did the live stream disappear yeah they they
sent me a picture of midnight mahjong i'm sorry he worked so
hard on it too he worked do you want to say anything are you
are you too disappointed to say it i know you're listening
because you sent me a picture of midnight mahjong i he said
there you go midnight mahjong oh my god maybe i should go to
midnight mahjong he's not saying anything why aren't you
saying anything say something say please say something and I
like this oh there you go is just another council experience
in the end not in the end see why are they playing mahjong
this is not
I don't know how to play mahjong is that crazy as someone
that's born from a Chinese family I don't understand mahjong
and I've seen my family play so much mahjong and I still
don't know how to play mahjong I like the funny table is the
oh it's not no it's not it's outside AX but it's outside
it's not inside it's like i just i just see i like the cool
fancy tables that do the little shuffle shuffle with the
majang but yes uh lolly thank you super chat thank you thank
you but um but yes he worked very very you know what guys
i'll give you guys okay so i'll give you guys a little sneak
preview um so you'll have to be at the outfit reveal i'll be
releasing a limited edition bundle with 69 i get to choose
the number where there's only 69 in stock and if you order
the limited edition bundle uh that only has 69 in stock by
the way uh nice yeah i know You will get a customized,
personalized, illustrated checky from me.
That's right.
And there's only 69 of them.
And I will number them.
So whoever gets 69, I bet you that's going to be worth
millions.
I better see that on eBay.
And that's going to be scalped.
Yeah.
And it comes with a free doctrine.
Well, it'll be numbered A and B.
Is there anyone that got A and B?
Who has one of the A's and B's?
Millions of what?
Pennies.
What if I never make a 60?
I just don't write a 69 one.
It's like 67, 68, and then I write 68B, and no one's ever,
no one, and then we're like, where's the 69?
Which dragon got the 69?
Yeah, it calls them 69, and you write, it's like 69A, 69B,
69C, and I go ahead, thank you for the Akasufo, thank you,
thank you, Toki, don't you.
do this my heart can't handle it thank you for the akasupa
thank you thank you you know what i'm feeling x i'm feeling
good right now guys you know as a treat for you guys because
i don't i i'm sorry it's not a real birthday stream i'm so
sorry but i hope you guys still enjoy hanging out with me
and just but i will spoil another merch for you guys that
will be releasing um because you guys already know that it's
a uh pajama it's a pajama themed um uh it's a pajama themed
bundle and i'm gonna do it manager i'm gonna show it to them
um it's it's gonna build hype you don't understand this is
gonna build hype um wait can you send me that wait send me
this
send it to me I need the PNG the just that one though it's a
dog it's a dog pajama it's I wish I'm not allowed I'm
Hawaiian pajamas I'm not allowed to make dog shirts anymore
don't know why they don't know why my staff won't let me
make dog shirts anymore I don't know why I'm not I thought I
was gonna make it big in the dog shirt industry guys I
thought I was gonna be the next Gucci for dogs I wonder why
it's gonna be the next prodigy designer for dogs next newly
baton for dogs work i got i thought i was a really good dog
shirt designer i was just i was just too young for like i
was just what's the word it's born in the wrong time it's
just a born in the wrong generation to be able to appreciate
my dog shirts I was ahead of my time.
Exactly.
I'm ahead of my time.
I bet you in like 20 years, my dog shirts are going to fly
off the shelves.
So, thank you.
I'm a magenta soup, but thank you.
Thank you.
Happy birthday, dog.
It was my first time being at a concert.
It was amazing.
Please take the 68B dollars as a present.
Thank you for the magenta soup, but thank you.
Thank you.
I want to know who got 60, who got A and B, guys.
It's your mission to find your twin.
I gave you a side quiz and you're not starting it like I
gave you a side quest we need to find your twin
all right so I'm gonna I'm gonna spoil you guys with one of
the merch in the bundle and you guys are gonna like this
because it's finally real
Yes, that's right.
After talking about this for a fucking two years, I'm out of
it.
See, thank you, thank you.
You're Australian, you be the bluey futon.
Thank you, the same, thank you, thank you.
But Toki, Toki, I don't understand.
This is a tool pack, though.
So, so you see, I got the council again.
Um, so I don't know why I keep using the council I so I got
the council again and then so there was a choice between two
and the council decided to have the crouch mouth the council
strikes again in the in the dick mouth so why yeah and but I
was just like okay that's funny but you know what's funnier
though the council what if your ass was a tomato so I fly it
was funnier if if it's like your ass is looking back at you
you know you turn around is like somebody walking away and
his ass is looking at you so it's like the dickle or the
asshole so don't keep please so i thought it was funnier if
if the mouse was if the mouth was on the ass so i love to
see her why away so me and the council fought over this
because they're like no no when it's on the front it's funny
like no when it's on the back it's funnier um so in the end
we had a compromise what if you can buy both boxers and you
can pick and choose how you feel we had a negotiation and we
struck a deal so we're like why the talk shirt's 2.0 this is
good no this is it yes i found the formula so now the
council fought back so now you guys have a choice between um
between two you can have the tomato in the front or the
tomato in the back and yeah two pack It's how you feel,
guys.
It's how you...
Oh, shit.
That's not it.
That's...
I clicked the wrong one.
This is when Min and I did their Phantom Thief concert.
I still have that.
So, you're like, guys, and then...
Anyway.
So, you guys remember the inspiration?
I sent this as the concept, right?
It's finally here, guys.
We finally did it.
We finally made tomato boxers.
reality after two years guys after two years we finally have
it the way it became remember this concept that I drew two
years ago dreams the dreams do come true it really does
it's been a long road who asked i asked for this
so yes imagine going on a date and going all the way because
of my boxers you're welcome dragoons i know if you have a
boyfriend dragoons you know what they want if you have a
girl girlfriend dragoons you know what they want to see it's
unisex too if you think about it it's perfect it's perfect
for four face yeah yeah and it's bright red too guys it's a
bright red so yeah at the finish line.
Can I get the eyes on both sides, please?
Thank you for the super chat, Mr. Broken Bond.
Thank you, thank you.
And thank you for the super chat.
What do you mean?
You're going to fight off the ladies after you wear these
boxers.
They won't keep their hands off you.
Or you can buy both and then cut in at half and sew both
faces together so you can get at the front and the bath back
guys the front side and the back side ladies of ladies
please there's a tomato for everyone next time glow in the
back guys the golden thing of the super chat thank you thank
you so i hope you guys look forward to next week when i come
back from la and then good luck with the 69 checkies
everybody uh good luck everyone I hope you guys fight well.
Yeah, it'll be, where is your Twitter?
Yeah, I mean, it's Saturday, so I'll be back around next
week, obviously.
But yes, it will only be 69.
Not 100.
Please announce the times for that.
It'll be customized.
Because I don't do a lot of autographs.
personal autograph stuff my manager tells me not to because
he doesn't believe in me um he's like you're not gonna he's
like you're always so busy when are you gonna do it i was
like i'm gonna do it but prove you wrong prove you wrong i
say as i didn't open the shop today proving him right i he
was he was he worked so hard on the shop guys hard on the
shop.
I'm sorry.
And also, I'm sorry to my distributor.
I'm sorry, Novels Cafe.
They both, they both worked so hard to make sure it could be
open today.
They didn't get in there.
They were like, we were like talking, we have so many things
we're dude, we want to launch this today.
The rest in peace.
So, anyway, I want to go to Midnight Mahjong.
I'm tired of this crap.
I want to know if there's actually going to be a fight.
The IT guy was like, yeah, there's a fucking big-ass fight
during Midnight Mahjong.
I was like, why?
For Mahjong.
like yeah I'm leaving right away I'm staying for a couple of
days like uh I'm not going I guys I need a couple of days of
relaxation right now damn because they are planning on
fixing the spawn um the spawn vod so I hope you guys um I
hope it gets fixed soon too I'm gonna ask if like polish it
uh if they if they can adjust stuff a bit more for the
upload we'll see we'll see uh because i want to have more
focus when if i upload it on the channel i want the focus to
be more on um we can still have like uh because it's like
the fanaf one the fanaf uh one where uh it was like
to the uh they had cuts to the uh audiences but it wasn't
like super all the time because I went for the concert
upload to focus more on the performance itself so I want to
edit the um see if they can edit it so to have like some of
the angles more on the performance versus like uh focusing
on like the audience POV and stuff too because I it's like
concert upload on YouTube I like to have it focus on the
song itself too so yeah I want have that as well to be
worked on.
Saw us, Link.
Thank you, the Magenta Super.
Thank you.
Still got some minutes left.
Felice Simplano.
Stokie.
You achieved incredible things today.
Have a blast watching St. You're amazing.
Can't wait for many more things to come.
Get some good rest and enjoy your birthday trip.
Thank you for the Magenta Super.
Thank you.
And then you're super chat.
If Mexico loses, we'll put the blame on No, no, no, guys, I
know, don't blame me, it's on my phone, guys, don't do it,
if make you go loses, then all we have is you, don't make me
into sunset, guys,
but yeah, I want to call, oh, guys, look at that, I'm ending
before my birthday, so you can't bully me now, Yeah, I can't
get to me.
Yeah, it's still my birthday, so you gotta be mean to me.
But yeah, anyways, thank you all for coming to the concert.
I can't believe it's finally over.
I can't believe it happened.
It happened.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe it happened.
I can't believe it's over.
And I can't believe everybody had an amazing time.
Okay, wait, who won?
Oh, 99 red balloons.
on on oh my god it was a close race all right 99 red did
like all of germany voted for this
all right so i guess it's 99 red balloons um and um and feel
good um that would be the two videos that i'll be uploading
that was voted by you dragons guys remember you guys voted
for it i I let the let the viewers decide anyway it wasn't
you say but thank you all for coming to the concert thank
you all for watching the concert I was so worried about the
concert the entire time and um I'm so happy that all my
worries and all the stress and everything um washed away and
there's nothing to worry about because you guys really enjoy
the concert you guys loved it you guys sang along that's why
I want it that's what the set okay maybe you guys are gonna
bully me at 12.
I'm gonna know my birthday's gonna be there.
You guys are gonna be like, you bitch, I fucking hate you.
You guys are just socky-doky.
I only said it because I only said it because it was your
birthday.
And I'm like, yeah, I'm gonna cry and I'm gonna go to
midnight, my John.
And then I'm like, locked and loaded.
Get ready.
They're getting ready.
It's getting there.
15 seconds.
Hold.
Hold on, drag.
anyway guys um oh fuck all right give me bring it and come
on say it give me your best shot it's time
boo birthday over get it thank you for the super chat um
back thank you thank you is right you suck the date has
changed dragons open the voice saying that you love it yeah
because they use super chat thank you thank you um anyway
I'm really happy that you guys actually all enjoy the
concert because I wanted you guys to sing along have fun
make a throwback to this like nostalgia bait all you guys
and then like you know have a great concert and I'm happy
with the set list and I'm happy as love the new outfits and
everything and the new models and um basically I just want
to rewatch the VOD of everything like I said you can still
buy the VOD and can rewatch the concert as many times as you
guys want and we're planning on fixing the concert too so uh
and you guys want to buy the merch the merch is on pre-order
right now so uh you can
basically uh i don't even know when i should i should ask
them when the pre-order ends for merch but here is the merch
that you can get as well remember mama merch
so here is i can't believe you outbid my 1.4k on the
skateboard doki i hate you my shrine is ruined thank you for
the super chat steal thank you thank you thank you the
akasupa steal they could thank you i really appreciate it um
what else but yeah like i'm just glad in the end like
everyone enjoyed themselves and everyone just had a great
time because that's why i wanted for the concert and like
all the hard work everything that everybody put in the
producers the men's um the backstage every the choreo like
the 3d people i mean my guests all my guys i will say huge
thank you to all my guests for being part of my concert too
and there's being part like you know just just doing it you
know just doing like just being a part of it and like i owed
him so much i couldn't have the concert about them and they
all work incredibly hard and um i'm just glad it's over i'm
just glad like i'm glad it's done i don't have to worry
about it anymore um hey guys as always everybody say hi jay
the posture get up and run around get that blood flowing and
you stay up for me head to bed cause you deserve it i'll see
you guys next time everybody happy ex was it day old
birthday to me anyway bye bye everybody bye oh my gosh how
do i end my stream where's the door there's the tab there it
is give me a sec guys i'm kidding with the tabs and haven't
streamed on his laptop in eight years Bye-bye.
We'll have a real birthday.
Well, technically, it's not really a birthday stream
anymore, but like, it'll be birthday coded.
I'll show my birthday stuff.
But anyway, bye-bye, everyone.
Bye-bye.